welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine
today i have the pleasure of introducing
dr matthew walker as our guest on the
huberman lab podcast
dr walker is a professor of neuroscience
and psychology at the university of
california berkeley
there his laboratory studies sleep
they study why we sleep what occurs
during sleep such as dreams and why we
dream learning during sleep
as well as the consequences of getting
insufficient or poor quality sleep on
waking states
dr walker is also the author of the
international bestselling book why we
sleep
our discussion today is an absolutely
fascinating one for anyone that's
interested in sleep learning or human
performance of any kind
dr walker teaches us how to get better
at sleeping
he also discusses naps whether or not we
should or should not nap whether or not
we can compensate for lost sleep and if
so how to best do that
we discuss behavioral protocols and
interactions with light temperature
supplementation food exercise sex
all the variables that can impact this
incredible state of mind and body that
we call sleep
during my scientific career i've read
many papers about sleep and attended
many seminars about sleep yet
my discussion with dr walker today
revealed to me more about sleep sleep
science and how to get better at
sleeping than all of those papers and
seminars combined i'm also delighted to
share that dr walker started a podcast
that podcast entitled the matt walker
podcast releases its first episode this
month and is going to teach all about
sleep and how to get better at sleeping
so be sure to check out the matt walker
podcast on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts before we begin i'd
like to mention that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public
in keeping with that theme i'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is roca
roca makes sunglasses and eyeglasses
that are of the absolutely highest
quality
the company was founded by two
all-american swimmers from stanford and
everything about the design of their
glasses is with performance in mind
i've spent my career studying the visual
system and how it works i can tell you
that roka glasses take into account the
science of the visual system such that
whether or not you're wearing them on a
very bright day or you walk into a
shadowed area or there's cloud cover you
can still see everything with perfect
clarity that also reflects the fact that
the lenses that they use are of the
absolute highest optical quality the
other terrific thing about roka
sunglasses and eyeglasses is that
they're designed to be worn in all
conditions you can use them while
running while cycling even if you get
sweaty they won't slip off
and they look great
one problem i have with a lot of
so-called performance eyeglasses and
sunglasses out there is that they look
crazy they make people look like cyborgs
roka glasses have a terrific aesthetic
you can wear them to dinner you can wear
them at work and you can wear them in
all sorts of sports activities if you'd
like to try roka glasses you can go to
roca that's
roka.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20 off your first order that's roka
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout today's podcast is also brought
to us by inside tracker inside tracker
is a personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and
dna to help you better understand your
body and reach your health goals i've
long been a believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that many of the factors that impact
your immediate and long-term health can
only be analyzed from a quality blood
test and nowadays with the advent of dna
tests you can also get insight into your
immediate and long-term health by way of
understanding your dna
one issue with many dna and blood tests
however is that you get the numbers back
about metabolic factors hormones genes
etc but there's no directive as to what
to do with that information with inside
tracker they have a very easy to use
dashboard and that dashboard not only
gives you your numbers but it gives you
simple directives related to nutrition
supplementation exercise and other
lifestyle factors that allow you to move
those numbers into the ranges that are
right for you and your health goals
if you'd like to try inside tracker you
can go to insidetracker.com
huberman and if you do that you'll get
25 percent off any of inside tracker's
plans just use the code huberman at
checkout today's episode is also brought
to us by belcampo belcampo is a
regenerative farm in northern california
that raises organic grass-fed and
finished certified humane meats i don't
need a lot of meat i meet about once a
day but when i do i make sure that it's
high quality and both humanely and
sustainably raised
conventionally raised animals are
confined to feedlots and eat a diet of
inflammatory grains but belcampo's
animals graze on open pastures and
seasonal grasses resulting in meat
that's higher in nutrients and healthy
fats and i've talked many times before
on this podcast about how getting
sufficient levels of omega-3s
is very important for metabolic health
hormone health mood essentially all
aspects of one's health belcampo meats
have high levels of omega-3s because of
the grasses they feed on
the way bell kempo raises its animals
isn't just better for our health it also
has a positive impact on the environment
they practice regenerative agriculture
which means that their meat is climate
positive and carbon negative meaning
it's good for you and it's good for the
environment
you can order bell campos sustainably
raised meats to be delivered to you
using my code huberman by going to
belcampo.com hubermann and if you do
that you'll get 20 off your first order
i'm a big fan of their keto meatballs i
also really like their boneless rib eyes
i eat those pretty much once a day again
that's huberman for the code and it's
balcampo.com
huberman for 20 off your order and now
my discussion with dr matt walker
great to finally meet you in person
wonderful to connect um i mean it's been
too long but i suspect it would have
been a shorter time before we'd met
lest the pandemic yeah um thank you
thank you yeah i'm delighted that we're
finally sitting down face to face i've
been tracking your work both in the
internet sphere and i read your book and
loved it and also from the perspective
of science you actually came to stanford
a couple of years ago and gave a a
lecture
uh for brain mind oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and um
there of course uh you talked about
sleep and its utility and its challenges
and how to uh
and how to conquer it so to speak um
let's start off very basic
what is sleep
sleep is probably the single most
effective thing you can do to reset your
brain and body health so that's a
functional answer in terms of you know
what is sleep in terms of its benefits
sleep as a process though is an
incredibly complex physiological ballet
and if you were to recognize or see what
happens to your brain and your body at
night during sleep you would be blown
away
and the paradox is that most of us and i
would think this too you know if i
wasn't a sleep scientist we go to bed we
lose consciousness for seven to nine
hours
and then we sort of wake up in the
morning and we generally feel better
and in some ways that denies the
physiological and biological beauty of
sleep
so upstairs in your brain when you're
going through these different stages of
sleep the the changes in brainwave
activity are far more dramatic than
those that we see when we're awake and
we can speak about deep sleep and what
happens there rem sleep is a fascinating
time which is another stage of sleep
often called dream sleep which is rapid
eye movement sleep
that stage of sleep some parts of your
brain are up to 30 percent more active
than when you're awake
so again it's kind of violating this
idea that our mind is dormant and our
body is just simply quiescent and and
resting so i would happy to sort of
double click on either one of those and
also what changes in the body as well
but it is an intense evolutionary
adaptive benefit um and system
that said though i i would almost push
back against uh an evolved system
when we think about the question of
sleep and what sleep is
our assumption has always been that we
evolved to sleep
and i've actually questioned that and i
have no way to
get in a time capsule and go back and
prove this but
what if we started off sleeping
and it was from sleep that wakefulness
emerged
why do we assume that it's the other way
around
and i think there's probably some really
good evidence that sleep may have been
the proto state that it was the basic
fundamental living state
and when we became awake as it were we
always had to return to sleep
you know in some ways at that point
sleep was the price that we paid for
wakefulness and that's another way of
describing what sleep is
but again i think it sort of denies that
the active state of sleep it's not a
passive state of sleep either
and then finally you can say what what
is sleep across different species and in
us human beings and in all mammalian
species and avian species as well sleep
is broadly separated into these two main
types and we've got non-rapid eye
movement sleep on the one hand and then
we've got rapid eye movement sleep on
the other
and we can speak about how they unfold
across a night and their architecture
because it's not just intellectually
interesting from the perspective of what
sleep is it's also practically impactful
for our daily lives and i'd love to sort
of go down that route too but you
navigate you tell me i can let's
definitely go down that route so um you
mentioned how active the brain is during
certain phases of sleep when i was
coming up in science
rem sleep rapid eye movement sleep was
referred to as paradoxical sleep is that
still a good way to think about it
paradoxical because the brain is so
active and yet we are essentially
paralyzed correct yeah it really is a
paradox and
where that came from was simply the
brainwave recordings
that if all i'm measuring about you is
your brainwave activity
it's very difficult for me sitting
outside of the sleep laboratory room to
figure out are you awake
or are you in rem sleep because those
two patterns of brain activity are so
close to one another you can't
discriminate between them
yet the paradox is that when you are
awake i go in there and you're sort of
sitting up you're clearly conscious and
awake but yet when you go into rem sleep
you are completely paralyzed
and
that's one of the i think that's part of
the paradox but the paradox really just
comes down to two dramatically different
conscious states
yet brain activity is dramatically more
similar than different and the way i can
figure out which of the two you are in
is by measuring two other signals the
activity from your eyes and the activity
from your muscles
so when we're awake we will occasionally
have these blinks and we'll have sort of
circads but during rem sleep you have
these really bizarre horizontal
shuttling eye movements that occur and
that's where the name comes from rapid
eye movements are they always horizontal
mostly they are horizontal and that's
one of the ways that we can
differentiate them from other waking eye
movement activity because it's not
always like it can be sometimes
horizontal but can also have diagonal
and also vertical in that plane
but then the muscle activity is the real
dead giveaway
just before you enter rem sleep your
brain stem which is where the dynamics
of non-rem and rem are essentially
played out and then expressed upstairs
in the cortex and downstairs in the body
when we go into rem sleep and just a few
seconds before that happens the brain
stem sends a signal all the way down the
spinal cord and it communicates with
what are called the alpha motor neurons
in the spinal cord which control the
voluntary skeletal muscles
and it's a signal of paralysis
and when you go into dream sleep you are
locked into a physical incarceration of
your own body
amazing you know why why would mother
nature do such a thing
and it's in some ways very simple
the brain paralyzes the body so that the
mind can dream safely
because think about how quickly we would
have all been popped out of the gene
pool you know if i think i'm you know
one of the best skydivers who can just
simply fly and i've had sometimes those
dreams too you know and i get up on my
apartment window and i leap out
you're done you're done yeah you know
so that's one of the sort of that's part
of the paradox of rem sleep both its
brain activity similarity despite the
behavioral state being so different and
this bizarre lockdown of the
sort of brain of the body itself now of
course the involuntary muscles
thankfully aren't um paralyzed so you
keep breathing your heart keeps beating
is this why men have erections during
rem sleep and women have vaginal
lubrication during sleep that's one of
the reasons part of the other reason
though though is because of the
autonomic activity so there is a nervous
a part of our nervous system called the
autonomic nervous system and it controls
many of the automatic behaviors
and some of those are aspects of our
reproductive facilities
during rem sleep what we later
discovered is that you go through these
bizarre what we call autonomic storms
which sounds dramatic but it actually is
when you measure them
that you'll go through periods where
your heart rate decelerates and drops
and your blood pressure goes down and
then utterly randomly your heart rate
accelerates dramatically and what we
call the fight or flight branch of the
autonomic nervous system or the
sympathetic nervous system badly named
because it's anything but sympathetic
it's very aggravating and
that all of a sudden fires up and then
it shuts down again and it's not in any
regular way
and it's when you get those autonomic
storms you get very activated from a
physiological perspective that you can
have these erections and you have
vaginal discharge etcetera you're
totally paralyzed but you are still
paralyzed there are only um
two
voluntary school
two voluntary muscle groups that are
spurred from the paralysis bizarre one
your extraocular muscles because if they
were paralyzed you wouldn't be able to
have rapid eye movements
and the other that we later discovered
was the inner ear muscle
and we've got
no good understanding as to why those
two muscle groups are spurred from the
paralysis it may have something to do
with cranial nerve
but i i don't think it's that i think
it's perhaps something more sensory
related some people have argued that the
reason the eyeballs are spurred from the
paralysis is because if your eyeballs
are left for long periods of time
inactive you may get things such as
oxygen sort of issues in the um
aqueous or vitreous humor and so the
eyeballs have to keep the drainage
systems of the anterior eye are made to
require movement exactly people with
glaucoma have deficits in in drainage
through the anterior chamber but there
i'm speculating i'm also speculating
when i ask this um
i would imagine that there are states in
waking that also resembles slow wave
sleep or rather that there are states
that slow wave sleep also resembles
waking states you've beautifully
illustrated how rem sleep
can mimic some of the more active brain
states that we achieve in waking
what sort of waking state that i might
have experienced or experience on a
daily basis might look similar
to slow wave sleep non-rem sleep if any
it's a genius way of thinking about it
turns the tables i love it um we almost
never see anything like the the
true ultra slow waves of deep non-rem
sleep so um we spoke about these two
stages non-rem and rem um non-rem is
further subdivided into four separate
stages um stages one through four
increasing in their depth of sleep so
stages three and four that's what we
typically call deep non-rem sleep stages
one and two so maybe take me through the
arc of a night just so that yeah yeah so
i put my head down uh well for you what
time do you normally go to sleep so i'm
usually sort of around about a 10
30 p.m guy and usually i'll naturally
wake up sort of a little bit before
seven sometimes before 6 45 or 7. i have
an alarm set for um 704 um a.m you heard
it here folks matt walker does use an
alarm clock i really really i'm usually
he doesn't recommend it but he does use
it yeah i usually human after all oh i
am so human um and and i've had my sleep
issues and i'd love to speak about that
too but um it's only just you know in
the event that um you know because i
like to keep regularity too you've got
to keep those two things in balance and
704 just because you know
why not be idiosyncratic i don't know
why we always set things up on these uh
hard numbers
so
yep so when you go to sleep around 10
30. so using you as an example um
because i imagine a number of people go
to sleep at different times with 10 30
is about when i go see 11 is for me but
um so you go to sleep at 10 30. so for
that first
um let's say three hours of sleep what
is the architecture of that sleep look
like as compared to the last three hours
of your sleep before morning yeah so i
should note that that sort of you know
10 30 to 7 that's just based on my
chronotype and my preferential it's
different for different people i'm not
suggesting that that's the perfect sweet
spot for humanity's sleep it's just my
but i imagine most people probably go to
sleep somewhere between
10 and
p.m and midnight and
like
5 a.m and 7 a.m or 5 30 and 7 30. yeah
yeah um at least in if you look at sort
of first world nations that's that's a
typical sleep profile
um so
when i first fall asleep i'll go into
the light stages of norm sleep stages
one and two of non-rem and then i'll
start to descend down into the deeper
stages of non-rem sleep so after about
maybe 20 minutes i'm starting to head
down into stage three non-rem and then
into stage four non-rem sleep
and as i'm starting to fall asleep as
i've cast off from the
usually with me murky waters of
wakefulness and i'm in the shallows of
sleep stages one and two my heart rate
starts to drop a little bit and then my
brainwave pattern activity starts to
slow down normally when i'm awake it's
going up and down maybe 20 30 40 50
times a second
as i'm going into light non-rem sleep it
will slow down to maybe 15 20 and then
really starts to slow down down to about
sort of ten or eight cycles per second
eight cycle waves per second
then as i'm starting to move into
stages three and four non-rem sleep
several remarkable things happen all of
a sudden my heart rate really does start
to drop
oh and i'll come back to temperature i'm
going to write temperature down because
i always forget these things um now i'm
sadly in the foothills of middle age um
so
as i'm starting to go into those deeper
stages of non-rem sleep
all of a sudden hundreds of thousands of
cells in my cortex all decide to fire
together and then they all go silent
together
and it's this remarkable
physiological coordination of the likes
that we just don't see at during any
other brain state that's really
interesting having recorded from the
brains of animals and a little bit from
humans i don't think i've ever seen the
entire cortex or even entire regions of
cortex light up like that yeah it's it's
stunning it's it's almost like this
beautiful sort of mantra chant
um or this sort of you know it's a slow
inhale and then a meditative exhale
inhale exhale and these waves are just
enormous in their size and the body is
capable of movement at this time there
is no paralysis there is no paralysis
but for the most part muscle tone has
also dropped significantly interesting
at that point
and then you will or i will then stay
there for about another 20 or 30 minutes
so now i'm maybe 60 or 70 minutes into
my first sleep cycle
and then i'll start to rise back up back
up into stage 2 non-rem sleep and then
after about 80 or so minutes i'll pop up
and i'll have a short rem sleep period
and then back down i go again down into
non-rem up into rem
and you do that reliably repeatedly and
i will be doing that and i do do that
every 90 minutes at least that's the
average for most adults it's different
in different species
what changes to your question is the
ratio of non-rem to rem within that
90-minute cycle as you move across the
night and what i mean by this is in the
first half of the night the majority of
those 90-minute cycles are comprised of
lots of deep non-rem sleep that's when i
get my stage three and four of deep
non-rem sleep
once i push through to the second half
of the night now that seesaw balance
changes and instead the majority of
those 90-minute cycles are comprised
either of this lighter form of non-rem
sleep stage 2 non-rem sleep and much
more an increasingly more rapid eye
movement sleep
and the implication that i was sort of
speaking about pragmatically is
let's say that
um i have to and i usually never do
early morning flights or red eyes um
just because i'm a mess if that happens
i'm not suggesting that other people
shouldn't i'm suggesting just will not
do that every time i've taken a red eye
or i've done that two or three days
later i get some sort of general feeling
of malaise my brain doesn't work as well
i i think red eyes should be abolished i
for the pilots too i mean and
we can forget about those and for the
emergency room i mean long shifts have
been shown to lead to you know
physician-induced uh errors that uh lead
to a lot of fatalities i mean there are
a lot of reasons why staying up too long
or being up at the wrong times if you're
not adapted to is just terrible the data
in all of those cases you know and
particularly physicians too there was
some recent data looking at suicidality
and the rates of suicide in training
physicians are you know far far above
the norm and i don't suspect that
you know their schedules are helping
them i suspect that sleep is a missing
part of that explanatory equation but i
teach medical students and and they
they're phenomenal but yeah they're
under extremely challenged conditions
it's uh we shouldn't put them under no
it's not it's not optimizing performance
um i'm sorry i'm sorry no no this is
important these um
it's an important digression i have one
question which is you're saying that as
across the night
a greater percentage of these 90-minute
cycles are going to be occupied by rem
sleep as you progress through the night
i'm aware that they're based on work
that you've done and uh and from your
public education efforts and others um
that
we have so-called circadian
forces and we have other forces that are
driving when we sleep and when we want
to sleep et cetera without going into
the details of those have a simple
question the experiment is the following
let's say god forbid you are prevented
from going to sleep at your normal time
and you stay up for the four hours or
five hours that normally you would be in
predominantly slow wave sleep yep if
let's say you finally get to lie down at
3 am
a time when normally your sleep would be
occupied mostly by rapid eye movement
sleep
will you experience a greater percentage
of rapid eye movement sleep because of
these so-called circadian forces meaning
that's what's appropriate for that time
or will your system need to start at the
beginning of the race that were
as as i'm referring to it that we're
calling sleep yeah and for if that's not
clear to anybody basically what i'm
asking is if you are forced to skip the
slow wave sleep part of the night will
your system
leap into
rapid eye movement sleep or does it have
to start at the beginning and get slow
wave sleep first in other words does one
sleep state drive the entry to the next
sleep state great question so there is
some degree of reciprocity between the
sleep states i should note that when we
drive one of those up we often but not
always see a change in the other there
are some pharmacologies that have shown
an independence to that and we've also
played around with things like
temperature and sometimes you can
you know nudge one and not seem to upset
or perturb the other
but to your um i think lovely point
the answer is it's a mix but it's mostly
the latter meaning you will mostly go
into your rem sleep phases
and be significantly deficient in your
deep sleep so just because i start my
sleep cycle at 3 00 am rather than at 10
30 pm
it doesn't mean that my brain just says
well i've got a program and i'm just
going to run the program and the way the
program runs is that we always start
with a first couple of hours of deep
sleep so we're just gonna begin act
number one scene one it doesn't do that
now i will get some deep sleep to begin
with
and part of that is just because of how
sleep works based on how long i've been
awake longer i'm awake there is a
significantly greater pressure for deep
sleep but we actually use
exactly what you just described as an
experimental technique to selectively
deprive people of one of those stages of
sleep or the other so we will do first
half of the night deprivation and then
let you sleep the second half so that
means that you will be mostly deep sleep
deprived and you will still get mostly
all of your rem sleep
and then we switch it so you only get
your first four hours which means you
will mostly get deep non-rem sleep but
you will get almost no rem sleep so in
both of those groups they've both had
four hours of sleep so the difference
between them in terms of an experimental
outcome is not the sleep time because
they've both slept for the same amount
it's the contribution of those different
stages now we actually have more elegant
methods for sort of selectively going in
there and scooping out different stages
of sleep but that's the way we used to
do it old school was just using this
timing difference and who suffers more
those that lack the early phase and
where those that lack the later phase of
the night sleep in other words
if i have to sleep only four hours for
whatever reason am i better off getting
the early part of the night's sleep or
the second half of the night's sleep
depends on what the outcome measure is
um so that gets right to the differences
between slow wave sleep and rem right i
was um probably misinformed but my
understanding a very crude understanding
i should i should say before i very much
doubt it's no contra with someone like
you yeah which is that they're very nice
of you but the the first part of the
night the slow wave sleep is restorative
to the musculature to motor learning and
that the dream content tends to be less
emotional the second half of the night
being more emotional dreams and sort of
the unpairing of the emotional load of
our previous day and other experiences
so in other words if i were to deprive
myself deprive myself excuse me of rem i
would be hyper-emotional not maybe not
as settled with the kind of experiences
of my life whereas if i had to have
myself of slow wave sleep i would feel a
more physical malaise is that correct or
is that far too simple and if it is too
simple please uh tell me where i'm wrong
no i think much of that is correct and
it's sort of that plus
so
for example during deep non-rem sleep
that's where we get this it's almost a
form of natural blood pressure
medication and so when i take that away
from you the next day we're usually
going to see autonomic dysfunction we're
usually going to see abnormalities in
heart rate blood pressure we also know
that during deep non-rem sleep that
there is a certain control of specific
hormones for example we know that the
insulin regulation of sort of metabolism
meaning how will you look from a
regulated blood sugar perspective versus
dysregulated pre-diabetic look of
profile
that's where deep sleep seems to matter
if we selectively deprive you of that we
can see them
growth hormone is different actually so
that's that's a beautiful demonstration
where growth hormone seems to be more
rem sleep dependent and that's why we
can come on to the effects of alcohol
and there's some really impressive
frightening data on on alcohol in its
disruption of um of sleep
but then we also know testosterone
you know peak levels of testosterone
happen during rem sleep so the second
half of the night which is the second
half of the night so it really just
means that the
your profile of mental and physical
dysfunction will be different under both
of those conditions
which one would you prefer i would
prefer neither of them and it really
depends on what you're trying to
optimize for so it's it's just so
complex you know sleep is just so
pluripotent you know it's so
physiologically systemic
that
it's almost impossible not to undergo
one of those two things just deep sleep
deprivation or just rem sleep
deprivation and not show a profile that
you would really prefer to avoid
uh and that's that that's the reason
from an evolutionary standpoint that
we've preserved those stages of sleep i
mean sleep is just so idiotic you know
from an evolutionary perspective or
maybe waking is idiotic or waking is you
know well yeah i based on your previous
yeah who have you been talking to i
think that comment is very specific to
me um yeah i am normally um always an
idiot when waking but
i think this
this idea that sleep
you know is so profoundly detrimental to
us if you were to take it at face value
you know you're not finding a mate
you're not reproducing you're not
foraging for food you're not caring for
your young and worst of all you're
vulnerable to predation on any one of
those grounds sleep probably should have
been selected against but it wasn't
sleep has fought its way through
heroically you know every step along the
evolutionary path
and
therefore every sleep stage has also
survived as best we can tell
what that means is that those are
non-negotiable if mother nature had
found a way to even just sort of you
know
thin slice some of that sleep from us
there would have been vast i'm sure
evolutionary benefits but it looks as
though she hasn't and
i'm usually in favor of her wisdom after
3.6 million years so um yeah
it's incredible i want to introduce a
another um gadonkan experiment another
thought experiment so in this arc of the
night slow wave sleep predominates
early in the night and then rem sleep
there's a scenario that many people
including myself experience on a regular
basis which is
they go to sleep sleeping just fine
three four hours into it they wake up
yeah they wake up for whatever reason
maybe there's a noise maybe the
temperature isn't right we will
certainly talk about sleep hygiene etc
they get up they go to the restroom they
might flip on the lights they might not
they'll get back in bed
hopefully they're not picking up their
phone and starting to browse and wake up
the brain through various mechanisms
light and cognitive stimulation etc they
go back to sleep let's say after about
10-15 minutes they're able to fall back
asleep and then they sleep till their
more typical wake time yeah
how detrimental is that wake-up
episode or or um
event in terms of
longevity learning etc
i would love to sleep the entire night
through every night but most nights i
don't and yet i feel pretty good
throughout the day some days better than
others
so if you were to
kind of evaluate that waking episode
and compare it to
sleeping the whole night through
what are your what are your thoughts on
that
so i think if you're waking up sort of
frequently as you're describing
i would probably get your estate in
order because my guess is within the
next year you're going to be you're
going to be done for no i'm kidding you
absolutely kidding you it is perfectly
natural and normal particularly as we
progress with age you know children tend
to have typically more continuous sleep
now it's not that they aren't waking up
for brief periods of time they are and
in fact we all do when we come out the
other end of our sleep cycle at the end
of our rem sleep period of the 90-minute
cycle almost everybody wakes up
and we make a postural movement we turn
over because we've been paralyzed for so
long and the body will also like to
shift do we ever look around we ever
open our eyes position you some
sometimes people will open their eyes
but usually it's only for a brief period
of time and they usually never commit
those awakenings to memory right
your situation and it's my situation as
well i usually now at this stage of life
i don't sleep through the night i'll
usually have a bathroom
break and then i'll come back
that's perfectly normal
we tend to forget that in sleep science
we think of sleep efficiency so of the
total amount of time that you're in bed
how much of that percent time is spent
asleep
and we usually look to numbers that are
above 85 percent or more as a healthy
sleep efficiency so if you were to think
about me going to bed and i spend
you know let's say eight and a quarter
eight and a half hours of time in bed
with a normal healthy sleep efficiency i
still may be only sleeping a total of
seven and a half hours or seven and
three quarter hours meaning that i'm
going to be
awake in total not in one long bout
but i'm going to be awake for upwards of
30 minutes net some time
sometimes that can be after a 10 minute
you know dalliance after having gone to
the bathroom and i'm just gradually
drifting back off again
other times it will just be for a couple
of minutes and most of those you don't
commit
so i think we need to stop we don't need
to get too worried about
you know periods of time awake just
because we're not sleeping throughout
the night i would love to do that too
and i remember when i that used to
happen and it still happens occasionally
it feels great
it's a lovely thing it's a surprise
right it is now a surprise for the whole
night yeah it is a surprise but
for the most part i think we can be more
relaxed about that where we have to be a
bit more attentive though is if you are
spending long periods of time not being
able to get back to sleep and usually we
define that by saying if it's been 20 25
minutes
normally that's a time when we would
really say okay let's explore this
what's going on let's see what's
happening
the other thing is if it's happening
very frequently so even if you're um
you know not awake for 25 minutes
stretches but you're finding yourself
waking up and being consciously aware
that you've woken up for maybe six seven
or eight times throughout the night and
your sleep is very what we call
fragmented
the great science of sleep in the past
five or ten years has has been yes
quantity is important but quality is
just as important and you can't have one
without the other in terms of a good
beneficial next day outcome
you can't just get four hours of sleep
but brilliant quality of sleep and be
unimpaired nor can you get eight hours
of sleep but have very poor quality of
sleep and be unempowered the next day
so that's why i just sort of want to
asterisk this idea of let's not get too
worried about waking up and having some
time awake that's perfectly normal and
natural but if it's happening very
frequently throughout the night all
those periods of time are long stretches
of time upwards of 25 minutes then let's
look into it well i can assure you just
helped a lot of people uh feel better
about this waking up
episode that i and many other people
experience i i hope so because i i
because i think it's really important
that we
you know
i think i've been desperately guilty of
perhaps
you know early on being too puritanical
about you know sleep and
and and i've i've retrospected and i've
tried to explore why this was the case
you know it was almost sleep or else dot
dot dot you know
and at the time when i was starting to
write the book which was back in 2016
you know sleep was still a neglected
step sister in the health conversation
of today
and i could have certainly changed and
it's changing you know and not because
of my efforts but no i always my
colleagues i would say well i it's a
great um that you give a attribution to
your other people involved and of course
it's a big field but i think um you've
done a great service by cueing people to
the importance of this state
not just for avoiding troublesome
outcomes but also for optimizing their
waking state it's real you know i i view
sleep as this
period that feels good but we're not
aware of how it feels when we're in it
necessarily yeah um has tremendous
benefits when you're doing it well so to
speak and it has tremendous um
deficits when when we're not and i think
i think it was an important thing for
you to do to cue people to this issue
and i would say mission accomplished
that people are aware of the need for
sleep i think that knowing that waking
up in the middle of the night is normal
provided it's not too frequent is is
great and will also help people who may
have been overly concerned about that i
i do want to use this as an opportunity
to raise
something about the so-called uberman
schedule not to be confused with the
hubermann
um fortunately no one uh has confused
those yet um
some years ago there was a discussion
about the so-called ubermen schedule
meaning the superman schedule so that's
huberman without an h which i have
nothing to do with um if you read your
nietzsche this might this will have a
subtext but regardless um the uberman
schedule as i understand is one in which
um the person
elects to sleep in 90-minute bouts
spread throughout the day and night in
an attempt to get more productivity
and or reduce their overall sleep need
there was a paper published recently
that explored whether or not this is
good or bad for us maybe you just give
us the take-home message on that yeah so
these uberman like uh schedules and
there's lots of different forms of that
they tried to
essentially pie chart the 24-hour period
into short bouts of sleep with some
shorter or no well slightly longer
periods of wakefulness then short bouts
of sleep then wakefulness
you know you're i sort of made it i
think a quip it's almost like you're
sleeping like a baby you know because
that's the way that babies in 90 minutes
will sleep they all have you know these
brief naps then they're awake then
they're asleep in the rake and to the
chagrin of parents across the night it's
basically the same they're awake they're
asleep they're awake they sleep and
that's more the the schedule that these
types of protocols have
have suggested
and there was a really great
comprehensive review that found not only
that they weren't necessarily helpful
but they were actually really quite
detrimental and on almost every
performance metric whether it be task
performance whether it be physiological
outcome measures whether it even be the
quality of the sleep that they were
having when they were trying to get it
all of those were in a downward
direction
and it's not surprising if you look at
your the way that your physiology is
programmed if you look at the way your
circadian rhythm is programmed none of
that screams to us that we should be
sleeping in that way well i'm chuckling
because we always hear sleep like a baby
this is how babies sleep and uh i would
say don't sleep like a baby sleep like
an adult yeah i mean get your solid
eight hours billy crystal's line he was
a um you know a long-standing suffering
insomniac he says i sleep like a baby
i'm awake every 20 minutes you know and
i think this is another one of those
demonstrations that
when you fight biology you normally lose
and the way you know you've lost is
disease sickness and impairment
and i think if you sleep
in accordance with the natural
biological edict that we've all been
given
life tends to be both of a higher
quality and a longer duration yeah i
agree along those lines um i'm as a
vision scientist i've been very excited
by the work on these uh non-image
forming cells in the eye the so-called
melanopsin cells that inform the brain
about circadian time of day and i'm a
big proponent of people getting uh some
sunlight ideally sunlight but other
forms of bright light in their eyes
early in the day and when they want to
be awake
essentially during the phase of their
24-hour circadian cycle when temperature
is rising and then starting to get less
light in their eyes
as our temperature is going down in
terms of later in the day and in the
evening are there any adjustments to
that general theme that you'd like to
add or is
in any way no i think that's exactly
what we recommend right now which is try
to get at least
30 to 40 minutes of exposure to some
kind of natural daylight now there may
be parts of the world where you know
you're from you're from a rather cloudy
part of the world i am from yeah uh
liverpool england uh and uh the
northwest of england is not known for
its um beach resorts and fine weather uh
i remember i'd sort of i went back home
for a trip when i'd first been out uh in
california and i thought why is the sky
so low you know it's just you know
constantly out we joke that in um in the
uk
we usually have nine months of bad
weather and then three months of winter
and then that's your that's your entire
year of in terms of a climate but to
come to your point you're exactly right
try to get that daylight now it can be
you know working next to a window and
you're getting that natural sunlight but
that natural sunlight is even on a
cloudy day in england is usually far
more potent than anything that you'll
get from indoor lighting
despite you thinking sort of from a
perception-wise maybe they're much
closer than i would think
yeah i've been um sorry to interrupt
i've been a big proponent of there's a
an app called light meter which will
it's a free app i have nothing to do
with it that will allow you to
get a pretty decent measurement of the
amount of light energy coming toward you
and if you um hold it up to a cloudy
morning where you don't think it's very
bright out kind of a dismal day you'll
notice that there'll be a thousand two
thousand even you know five thousand
looks looks just being a measure of
brightness of course and then you can
point the same light meter toward an
indoor light that seems very bright and
very intense and it'll say 500 blocks
and you realize that the intensity as we
gauge it perceptually is not really what
the system is receiving so outdoor light
is key how do you
how do you get this natural stimulation
or um i should just say light
stimulation early in the day what is
your typical what does matt walker do to
get this light stimulation i am no
poster child but um usually i will um if
i'm working i usually work out most days
um and i shopped around and i found a
gym that has huge amounts of window
exposure facing to the east this is sad
this is gonna sound so
uh ridiculous you know matt walker
chooses a gym on the basis i love it the
solar input so he can you know there are
a lot of criteria for selecting gyms
this one is actually grounded in
physiology and biology and so and
selfishness about my own sleep that's
great so you so you get your exercise
and your light stimulation that's right
yep yep and so you're stacking cues for
wakefulness early in the day exactly so
both exercise and daylight are wonderful
cues for circadian rhythm alignment and
also circadian rhythm reset each day and
so i will use both exercise i mean i am
i'm neither a strong morning type or a
strong evening type and my preference to
exercise is probably sometime in the
middle of the day um probably somewhere
around 1 8 1 pm sorry not 1am um but i'm
usually working out probably around the
sort of seven
sort of 45 8
a.m time that's usually when i'll start
my workout and there i'll start with
cardio spin bike facing a window and
luckily for the most part here in
california there's usually sunlight
coming through but it doesn't matter to
me because just as you said
even when it's a cloudy day that looks
coming through of light the the
intensity is is splendid so i would
prefer to favor
my exercise just because for efficiency
too i want to get also working on the
day
i'll try to match my
exercise more with my circadian light
exposure than i would probably if i'm
going to do i really want to crush a
workout or do i want to just you know
make sure it's a good workout
i would prefer to work out you know at a
different time but i like that because
of the daylight and we can speak about
exercise timing at some point because
there's a lot of discussion around that
when is the right excess time to
exercise during sleep and we can sort of
bust some myths there too
um so
i think you're spot on with the
suggestion get some morning daylight try
to get that exposure usually at least 30
to 40 minutes there was some great work
recently coming out in the occupational
health domain where they moved workers
from offices that were just facing walls
and you know didn't have any exposure to
natural daylight and then they did a
time period during that study where they
actually were in front of a window and
working and they measured their sleep
and their sleep time and their sleep
efficiency increased quite dramatically
i'm forgetting the numbers now but i
think the increase in total sleep time
is well over 30 minutes and the
improvement in sleep efficiency was 5 to
10 percent you know and if you're
batting an 80
you know sleep efficiency average
we're a bit concerned about that
but add 10 percent to that now you're in
you know a great echelon of healthy
sleepers and all you did was just spend
some time working in front of windows
that's great and probably um folks might
want to consider spending a little less
time with sunglasses provided they can
do that safely you know driving etc
you're not alone with your exercise
behavior and facing ease so um the one
and only tim ferriss told me recently
that his morning routine nowadays
consists of jumping rope while facing
east to get the sunlight stimulation of
the eyes and um as
matt and i both know it has to be of the
eyes right yeah these portals are the
only way to to um convey to the rest of
the brain and body about the time of day
and wakefulness um
along the lines of wakefulness
i have a number of questions about
caffeine yeah the dreaded and beloved
caffeine i love caffeine but i like it
in relatively s um
restricted periods of time
so um
i'm a big fan of waking up and even
though i wake up very groggy allowing my
natural wakefulness signals to take hold
meaning i wake up very slowly but i
don't drink caffeine right away i sort
of delay caffeine by a little while
usually 90 minutes to two hours okay and
that idea came to me on the basis of my
understanding of how caffeine and the
adenosine receptor interact i have a
feeling you're going to pronounce
adenosine differently than i do no no i
will go with it i'll go with adenosine
i'll i'll try to go with your skeletal
and skeletal
synapse and synapse shed you on schedule
there we go but um
but to make it really simple for folks
how does caffeine work to make us feel
more alert and does the timing in which
we ingest caffeine
play an important role in whether or not
it works for us or against us so may we
just start with how does caffeine work
why is it that when i drink mate or
coffee which are my preferred sources of
caffeine do i feel a mental and physical
lift yeah so
i'm going to suggest counter to what
most people would think drink
coffee
or mate is mate okay yeah yeah whatever
form you will
will come on to sort of why i suggest
that but when it comes to
coffee uh i would say
the dose and the timing makes the poison
so
let's start with how caffeine works um
caffeine is in a class of drugs that we
call the psychoactive stimulants
so it works through a variety of
mechanisms
one is
a dopamine mechanism dopamine we often
think of as a reward chemical or
but dopamine is also very much an
alerting neurochemical as well and
caffeine has some role it seems to play
in increasing dopamine but it's
principal mode of action we believe in
terms of making me more alert and
keeping me awake throughout the day
is on the effects of adenosine
and to explain what adenosine is from
the moment that you and i woke up this
morning this chemical adenosine has been
building up in our brain
and the longer that we're awake the more
of that adenosine accumulates is it um
may i ask is it accumulating in neurons
in glia or in the blood vessels
where and and is it also accumulating in
my body where is this adenosine coming
from and where is it accumulating yeah
so the adenosine here that we're talking
about that is creating the sleep
pressure is a central brain phenomenon
and it comes from the neurons themselves
combusting energy
and as they're combusting energy one of
the offshoots of that
is this chemical adenosine okay and so
as we're awake throughout the day and
our brain is metabolically very active
it's accumulating and building up this
adenosine
now
the the more adenosine that we have the
sleepier that we will feel so it really
is like a sleep pressure is what we call
it now it's not a mechanical pressure
don't worry your head's not going to
explode it's a chemical pressure
and it's this weight of sleepiness that
we feel gradually growing as we get into
the evening
may i just interrupt you again to just
ask do we know what the circuit
mechanism is for that i mean not to um
go too far down the rabbit hole but for
the aficionados and for myself uh we
have brain mechanisms like locus
ceruleous that release things that are
brain areas locus thrillers just being a
brain area of course that release things
that create that proactively create
wakefulness yeah so are those neurons
shutting down as a consequence of having
too much
adenosine or are there areas of the
brain
that promote sleepiness that are being
coming activated because these you can
imagine both things working in parallel
one or the other would accomplish the
same endpoint yeah and it's it's both
and so there are two main receptors for
adenosine the a1 receptor and the a2
receptor and they have different modes
of activating brain cells or
inactivating or decreasing the
likelihood of firing and adenosine works
in this beautiful elegant way where it
will inhibit and shut down the wake
promoting areas of the brain whilst also
increasing and dialing up the volume on
sleep activating sleep promoting oh it's
always a push pull yeah i mean we and we
could have a larger discussion at some
point about that um everything seeing
dark edges seeing light edges uh yeah
our ability to to smell or to sense
pressure on this everything's a pushback
that's a great yeah yep so this is
another example where as i
am awake longer
adenosine is released in the brain and
my wakefulness areas are being actively
shut down by that adenosine and my
sleepiness brain areas so to speak are
being
promoted to be more active is that
correct that's right and it's a very
progressive process it's not like a step
function where and sometimes that
happens occasionally but it's usually
because you've been sort of driving
through and as will come on to have
caffeine in the system and then all of a
sudden you just hit a wall and it just
you know engulfs you and you go from a
zero to the one of sleepiness within a
short period of time explains the
fatigue after a hard conversation
the desire to go to sleep or the desire
to go to sleep during a hard
conversation um
that's an interesting i think it's
usually just based on personality type
interactions and for the most part not
that i've ever experienced that no
people with you don't but with me they
oh no no i mean i've experienced the
desire to some conversations
i'm halfway through them and i feel like
i want to take a nap yeah right um and i
would love to look at you know people's
sleep history we've sort of seen that
time and time again but um and then it
could be you know with with folks like
me people just lose the will to live
within about five minutes of speaking
with me so
they hear that sleep is important it's
unrelated and that's flattery that's
great but so the way that then caffeine
comes into this
equation as i was saying it's usually a
kind of a linear process or maybe it's
probably closer to an exponential in
terms of your subjective feeling of
sleepiness
and we haven't really been able to
measure that in humans because normally
we it's hard to actually you know stick
something into the brain and be you know
sucking siphoning off stuff every couple
of minutes as you could do in animal
studies and keep asking people every
couple of minutes how sleepy do you feel
how sleepy and track to see if there's a
linear rise in you know adenosine which
then creates an exponential rise in
subjective sleepiness or what the
dynamics are but i'm i'm kind of nerding
out
caffeine comes into play here because
caffeine
comes into your system and it latches
onto those welcome sites of adenosine
the adenosine receptors
but what it doesn't do is latch onto
them and activate them
because if it was doing that then it
would you know in lots of ways it would
dial up more
sort of sleepiness it does the opposite
the way that caffeine works is that it
comes in
competes with quite sharp elbows with
adenosine competitively forces them out
of the way
hijacks that receptor by latching onto
it but then just essentially blocks it
it doesn't
inactivate the receptor it doesn't
activate the receptor it
functionally inactivates it in the sense
that it takes it out of the game for
adenosine so it's it's like someone you
know coming into a room and you're just
about to sit down on the chair and
caffeine comes in and just pulls out the
chair and you're like well now i've got
nowhere to sit and caffeine just keeps
pulling out the chairs from adenosine
and adenosine even though it's at the
same concentration in your brain
your brain doesn't know that you've been
awake for you know
10 hours 16 hours at that point when
you've downed a cup of coffee
because all of that adenosine that's
still there can't communicate to the
brain
that you've been awake for 16 hours
because but the adenosine is still in
brain cells correct
so so the real question is what happens
when caffeine is dislodged from the
adenosine receptor
things happen and that's what we call
the caffeine crash which is caffeine has
a half-life and it's metabolized um and
you recall what the half-life is yeah
the half-life is somewhere between five
to six hours
and the quarter life therefore is
somewhere between 10 to 12 hours
it's variable different people have
different um durations of its action but
for the average adult five to six hours
that variation we understand it's down
to a liver enzyme or a set of liver
enzymes
of the class that we call the cytochrome
p450 enzymes and there are two i think
last i i delved into the data which is
pretty recently there are two gene
variants that will dictate the enzymatic
speed with which the liver breaks down
caffeine and that's why you can have
some people who are very sensitive to
caffeine and other people who say you
know i'm just doesn't affect me really
that much at all these are the people
that have a double espresso after a 9
p.m dinner and you can sleep just fine
well and we'll cover at least
subjectively they think objectively yeah
and we we should speak about that that
assumptive danger too
so
then the caffeine is in the system and
after some time period it will be
inactive in the system so let's say that
you know i've been awake for 12 hours
now and it's you know 8 p.m and i'm
feeling a bit tired but i want to push
through and i want to keep working for
another couple of hours so i have a cup
of coffee all of a sudden i was feeling
tired but i don't feel like i've been
awake for 12 hours anymore because with
the caffeine in the system maybe only
half of that adenosine
is being communicated through the
receptor to my brain 100 of the the
adenosine is still there only half of it
is allowed to communicate to my brain so
now i think oh i haven't been awake for
12 hours i've just been awake for six
hours i feel great then after a few
hours and the caffeine is starting to
come out of my system not only am i hit
with the same levels of adenosine that i
had before i'd had the cup of coffee
several hours ago it's that plus
all of the adenosine that's been
building up during the time that the
caffeine has been in my system so sort
of a an avalanche of it is a tsunami
wave yeah and i have a caffeine crash
and it's interesting because the
caffeine crash at uh two o'clock in the
afternoon when you have work to do is a
terrible thing but
what about the person
maybe this person is me in my 20s who
says i'm gonna drink caffeine all day
long
and then i want the crash because at 9
or 10 pm if i stop drinking caffeine at
say 6 pm
and i crash then i crash into a slumber
a deep night of sleep
is that sleep really as deep as i think
it is because given the half-life of
caffeine that
you mentioned a few moments ago
i have to imagine that having some of
that caffeine circulating in my system
might disrupt the
depth of sleep or somehow the
architecture of sleep in a way that even
if i get eight or who knows even 10
hours of sleep it might not be as
restorative as
i would like it to be yeah
and that is the danger just sort of that
you know those people that you described
who say and i a lot of them will um
speak with me too say look i can have
two espressos with dinner and i fall
asleep fine and i stay asleep because
usually those are the two phenotypes
that we typically see with too much
caffeine i just can't fall asleep as
easily as i want to or i fall asleep but
i just can't stay asleep and caffeine
can do both of those things quite
potently how late in the day do you
think is
assuming somebody translate this folks
if you go to bed earlier or later you
have to shift the hours accordingly but
given
somebody who typically gets into bed
around 10 10 30 and falls asleep around
11 11 30 yeah
when would you recommend they halt
caffeine intake and these are not um
strict prescriptives but i think people
do benefit from having some uh fairly
clear guidelines of what might might
work for them would you say cut off
caffeine by
what time of the day i would usually say
take your typical bedtime and count back
sort of somewhere between ten to eight
hours is probably getting a little bit
close but take back sort of 10 hours or
eight hours of time that's the time when
you should really stop
you know using caffeine is the
suggestion and the reason is because for
those people who even just keep drinking
up until you know the into the evening
you're right that they can fall asleep
fine maybe they stay asleep but the
depth of their deep sleep is not as deep
anymore
and so there are two consequences the
first is that for meat and it can be up
to by 30 percent and for me to drop your
deep sleep by 30 i'd have to age you by
between 10 to 12 years
or you can just do it every night to
yourself with a couple of espressos
the second is that
you then wake up the next morning and
you think well i didn't have problems
falling asleep and i didn't have
problems staying asleep but i don't feel
particularly restored by my sleep so now
i'm reaching for three or four cups of
coffee the next morning rather than just
two or three cups of coffee and so goes
this dependency cycle that you then need
your uppers to wake you up in the
morning and then sometimes people will
use alcohol in the evening to bring them
down because they're overly caffeinated
and alcohol and we can speak about that
too also has very deleterious impacts on
your sleep as well
so you're right that it's not just the
quantity of your sleep or even
difficulties falling or staying asleep
it can also be deep sleep but here again
i think you know i don't want to be
frightening people and i mentioned this
before i think one of the real problems
that i or mistakes that i made because i
didn't you know i'd never had much
public exposure before the book
um
and i was so saddened by you know the
disease and the suffering that i was
seeing as a consequence of a lack of
sleep in our society
and the fact that it wasn't really being
discussed very much
i sort of came out
you know a little bit headstrong more
than a little bit headstrong and i think
i was you know perhaps too
too much gas pedal and too little
you know break as it were
and
i don't think that's the right way to
approach
health
message within the public sphere and
i've become much softer in how i think
about these things
i have ideas about what the ideal world
looks like for sleep but i also realize
that none of us live in this thing
called the ideal world we certainly
don't so you know i want to be really
mindful of that and i think i've done a
really bad job of being sort of too
forthright particularly for people who
struggle with sleep you know early on
when i would offer these sort of
messages about sleep i want to be
you know
i want to be veritical when it comes to
the science i want to be faithful to the
science but i also don't want to go out
and scare the living daylights out of
people particularly people who are
struggling with their sleep because it's
probably only going to make matters
worse so i've been beautifully schooled
by um
learning how to be a slightly better
public communicator i'm nowhere near
understanding that that you are you're
very elegant and it's very intuitive to
you i'm still with training wheels but
i'm getting a little bit better but i
don't i just want to say that when i'm
speaking about caffeine because it
sounds as though i'm very um sort of
overt about it but i will come back to
why i say drink coffee um but i just
want to make that point yeah well i
appreciate you making that point and i'm
sure our listeners will too um i i still
will
stand behind my statement um
which is that what you've done for the
notion that sleep is vital for all
aspects of health and for performance
mental and physical and wakefulness
the message and that and the packaging
it was contained in and is has been
clearly clearly net positive people
needed to be queued to this
i'll sleep when i'm dead mentality is
one that i had it's one that other
people have um people in a huge number
of vital communities not just your your
students but also um people that this
the messaging that you provided and
continue to provide has positively
impacted the first responder community
the medical community there's still
steps that need to be taken the military
community and of course the civilian
community and so i think these
adjustments about yeah caffeine's okay
just restrict it to the early part of
the day if you can most days i mean i
think the law of averages it's like the
light viewing behavior
i think it is critical to view sunlight
or natural some other form of bright
light early in the day but if you miss a
day it's not that your whole system is
going to dissolve into a puddle of tears
that'll that'll happen on the second or
the third day no i'm kidding you get a
couple days biology works in averages
except with respect to accident or
injury a car accident is a car accident
right you don't get to have three of
those before the brain damage occurs if
the accident is severe enough yeah but
with sleep behavior these um homeostatic
type behaviors or with food one
chocolate sundae is it gonna kill you no
every night yeah it's gonna make you
demented and kill you early we know this
and so i think the
the middle ground is often a hard place
to achieve um so i think you've done a
phenomenal job but i appreciate you
raising these points and and i think um
it's clear
that we all need to that we all can and
should do certain things better
including
being gentle with ourselves from time to
time when we deviate from these uh these
ideal circumstances along these lines i
i do want to talk about alcohol because
i think caffeine and alcohol represent
the uh the kind of two opposite ends of
the spectrum clearly there are other
stimulants um there are your adderalls
and your uh high energy drinks that
people use but alcohol and caffeine are
are the most commonly consumed yeah
stimulants and and sedatives depressants
as they're sometimes called
so um
what happens
when somebody has a glass we always hear
a glass or two of wine in the evening or
a
a cocktail after dinner
or before dinner how does that impact
their sleep and then we'll be sure
to circle back in terms of what is
reasonable ranges of behavior when it
comes to
avoiding alcohol or
if it's age-appropriate etc enjoying
alcohol yeah
so alcohol if we're thinking about
classes of drugs they're in a class of
drugs that we call the sedatives
and i think one of the first problems
that people often mistake alcohol is
often used as a sleep aid
for people who are struggling with sleep
when things like over-the-counter
remedies etc or herbal remedies have
just not worked out for them and alcohol
unfortunately is anything but a sleep
aid
the first reason that most people use it
is to try and help them fall asleep
and this process of this event that we
call falling asleep i have to imagine is
a process it is like everything in
biology and that that process involves
in some way as we talked about push-pull
before turning off thinking planning
etc and turning on some sort of
relaxation mechanism i have to imagine
that these two things are knobs turning
in opposite directions this gives us
this outcome we call falling asleep
alcohol it seems is helpful for some
people
to
turn off their thoughts or their
planning is that right
yes it is and so i think you know if we
look at the pattern of brain activity if
i were to place you inside an mri
scanner where we're looking at the
activity of your brain and watch you
drifting off some parts of your brain
will become less active other parts will
become more active and this is the
push-pull model it's inhibition
excitation
but alcohol is quite different in that
regard alcohol is because it's a
sedative what it's really doing is
trying to essentially knock out your
cortex it's
sedating your cortex and sedation is not
sleep but when we have a couple of
drinks in the evening when we have a
couple of night caps we mistake sedation
for sleep saying well i always when i
have a couple of whiskeys or a couple of
cocktails it always helps me fall asleep
faster
in truth what's happening is that you're
losing consciousness quicker
but you're not necessarily falling
naturalistically asleep any quicker so
that's one of the first sort of things
just to keep in mind the second thing
with alcohol is that it fragments your
sleep and we spoke about the quality of
your sleep being just as important as
the quantity
and alcohol through a variety of
mechanisms some of which are activation
of that autonomic nervous system that
fight or flight branch of the nervous
system
alcohol will actually have you waking up
many more times throughout the night so
your sleep is far less continuous now
some of those awakenings will be of
conscious recollection the next day
you'll just remember waking up many of
them won't be
and so but yet your sleep will be
littered with these sort of punctured
awakenings throughout the night and
again when you wake up the next morning
you don't feel restored by your sleep
you know fragmented sleep or
non-continuous sleep in this alcohol
induced way
is usually not good quality sleep that
you feel great on the next day
the the third part of alcohol in terms
of an equation is that it's quite potent
at blocking your rem sleep your rapid
eye movement sleep and rem sleep is
critical for a variety of cognitive
functions um some aspects of learning
and memory it seems to be critical for
aspects of emotional and mental health
you've described it before as a sort of
self-generated therapy that occurs while
we sleep yeah it's overnight therapy you
know it's emotional first aid uh
certainly people that don't get enough
sleep um are very easy to derail
emotionally yeah not that one would want
to do that to people but we all sort of
fall apart
emotionally are i i always think about
almost like our skin sensitivity can be
heightened yes when we are sleep
deprived um our emotional sensitivity um
is such that when we're sleep deprived
such that it takes a um much
finer grain of sandpaper to create that
kind of friction yeah things bother us
it thresholds even online comments
bother us when we're sleep-deprived and
never when we're i would love to say
that i never look at them uh except i
look at
i should
maybe everyone here i will editorialize
because the notion of not looking at
comments is um is unreasonable for to
ask of any academic because academics we
are all trained to look at our teaching
evaluations yeah and just like with
online comments to ignore 20 of them no
i'm kidding we look at them all um in
any event so in terms of translating
this to behavior i'm not i don't
particularly enjoy alcohol i guess i'm
might be fortunate in that sense but i
also have never really experienced that
the pleasure of drinking uh alcohol i
sometimes like the taste of a drink but
i never liked the sensation so that's i
don't have a lot of familiarity with
this but many people do and i understand
that so let's say um
somebody uh enjoys a glass of wine or
two with dinner and they eat dinner at 7
p.m
is that likely to disrupt their sleep at
all let's just sort of let's make this a
series of gradations yeah and the answer
is yes um i think
one city just looked at a single glass
of wine in the evening with dinner and
i would be untruthful if i didn't just
simply say it has
an effect and we can measure that uh in
terms of lesser obviously less rem sleep
and one of the fascinating studies i
can't remember what dose i think they
got them close to a standard
illegal blood alcohol level so maybe
they were a little bit tipsy and yes you
see all of the changes that we just
described um they sort of lose
consciousness more quickly they have
fragmented sleep and they have a
significant reduction in rem sleep but
what was also interesting because rem
sleep as we spoke about before is a time
when some hormonal systems are
essentially recharged and refreshed
growth hormone being one of them there's
well over a fifty percent five zero drop
in their growth hormone release during
alcohol laced sleep at night wow and
growth hormone is so vital for
metabolism and repair of tissues and
yeah um
essential um along those lines i i just
want to highlight the fact that this um
this information that you're sharing
that growth hormone is released is
strongly tethered to the presence of
healthy amounts of rem sleep
is interesting to me because i always
thought the growth hormone was released
in the early part of the night well it
is released
across both of those but across the
different stages but what we also know
is that when you disrupt rem sleep there
are those growth hormone consequences so
it's not an exclusive system just like
with testosterone we can see changes
throughout non-rem sleep but if you ask
when are the peak release rates of
testosterone it's right before we go
into rem sleep and then during rem sleep
and of course testosterone being
important both for for males and females
right for libido and tissue repair and
well-being
nobody regardless of chromosomal
hormonal or any other background wants
to have their
normal levels of testosterone reduced
acutely that's just a bad it it equates
to a terrible set of psychological and
physical symptoms yeah and the mortality
risk that's associated with low
testosterone is non-trivial prostate
cancer right exactly you know so
coming back to
just the point on rem sleep that you
mentioned regarding emotional
instability and we see that that's one
of the things one of the most reliable
signatures of just insufficient sleep
doesn't have to be sleep deprivation
what we've
discovered over the past 20 years here
at the sleep center is that
there is no major psychiatric disorder
that we can find
in which sleep is normal
and so i think that firstly told us
there is a very intimate association
between your emotional mental health and
your sleep health
but when it also comes to rem sleep i
think what's fascinating is that
it's not just about your emotional
health it's not just about your hormonal
health um we've also been seeing other
aspects of you know cognition
but then there was a a report i think it
could have been about two years ago
out of harvard um i think it was beth
clearman's group
um
they found that and they replicated it
in two different large populations
if you look at the contribution of
different sleep stages to your lifespan
rem sleep was the strongest predictor of
your longevity
and it was a linear relationship but
wasn't it sort of one of these u-shaped
or j shaped curves that we often see
with total sleep and mortality risk it
really was linear that the less and less
rem sleep that you were getting the
higher and higher your probability of
death and then they did was that death
due to um natural causes or accidents i
could imagine if you're not getting
enough rem sleep you're more likely to
drive off the freeway step off a cliff
yeah i think it was all cool just make
bad decisions about anything like
relationships yeah which can also be
life-threatening yeah i've tried to lean
into that and claim that i um with those
bad relationship situations that oh i
just didn't have enough
last night my darling
yes and uh but uh she's far wiser than i
thought but um so
they did this great machine learning
analysis and i may get these numbers
backwards
but i think for every five percent
reduction in rem sleep there was a 13
associated increased risk of mortality
and i could have i'll have to go back
and and check but
to me
and in the machine learning algorithm
what they ultimately spat out was that
of all of the sleep stages rem sleep is
the most predictive of your longevity of
your lifespan
so we often i hear people saying how can
i get more deep sleep
or they sometimes say how can i get more
dream sleep and my answer is a question
why do you want to get more of that and
they'll say well isn't that the good
stuff
and i'll say well actually all stages
it's all the good sleep yeah well it's
like the exercise question and it took
decades for people to understand that
moving around at
for about 150 probably 180 minutes a
week at doing endurance type work zone 2
cardio type work it
is correlated with living longer feeling
better less diabetes etc there's really
no way around it i mean you can
um you can ingest metformin until the
cows come home
you can take nmn all of which i think
have have their place in
certain contexts i'm a big fan of the
work surrounding all those protocols
but without
getting proper amounts of movement
meaning sufficient numbers it doesn't
matter how many 12-minute exercise
regimes you follow per week you need
that
threshold level and it sounds like the
same is true of rem sleep and total
amount of sleep there's just
you um
you pay the piper somehow yeah the
return on investment i mean to flip the
coin the return on investment is is
astronomical you know i think of sleep
it is the tide that moves you know that
raises all of those health boats
and the most fundamental layer of mental
and physical health whenever people ask
me even though i'm not a physician
they'll ask me what what should i what
should i take or what should i do the
first question is always how's your
sleep greening how well do you sleep
every night and and how how long you see
my always recommend your book i always
recommend your podca your you know the
podcast you've been uh
a guest on et cetera um
who knows maybe you'll even release your
own podcast at some point soon and keep
because i do think people need to hear
from you more often one thing i i don't
want to return to the the notion of of
uh public health discourse too much but
i do want to say one issue with books in
general is that
they can be revised but it's more or
less a one and done kind of thing until
the next book comes out yeah one thing
that i like about the podcast format is
that updates can be provided regularly
corrections and updates as new data come
out and so that's a wonderful aspect to
this format and and uh hopefully the
format that you'll be
embracing i think the world needs to
hear
more from you more often about sleep and
its various contours um not less and
so i do have a question about uh
drinking alcohol not that we want to
promote day drinking but let's say that
the one
or two glasses of wine or cocktail is
consumed with lunch something that isn't
traditionally done nowadays or in a late
afternoon happy hour type cocktail and
then one is going to sleep seven or
eight hours later do you think that that
will
improve or somehow mitigate the effects
of alcohol or
if you have a drink are you basically
screwed for the next 24 hours no i think
there's going to be a
time window dependency now i don't know
of anyone who's essentially done what
you and i would like which is the time
separation dose dependent curve were
okay you drink at 10 am then or 11 12 1
2 3 4 5 all the way up to you know 10
p.m
and estimate what is the blast radius
and is it linear or is it non-linear is
it such that only when you drink in the
last four hours do you just hit this
exponential and it's bad bad bad or is
this some other curve that we could
imagine there would be many
possibilities
but certainly what we know is that the
less alcohol and the less and more
specifically the metabolic byproducts
aldehydes and ketones they're the sort
of the nefarious players and not the
ketones that people are all excited
about the other the other ketones yes
the chemists know what we're referring
to but this is not about kisogenesis
this is not about ketogenesis there are
ketone bodies and uh that are released
uh after ingesting alcohol that are not
of the positive sort correct that uh a
ketogenic diet might promote right yeah
so
i think in terms of that alcohol um
profile we certainly know that you know
as you're heading into the evening hours
once again timing and dose make the
poison
but i think it's also important once
again from that public uh message
standpoint and thank you i think i i i
am leaning into the sort of the podcast
uh consideration arena at some point but
i don't want to be puritanical here you
know i'm just a scientist and i'm not
here to tell anyone how to live all i'm
trying to do is
empower people with some of the
scientific literature regarding sleep
and then you can make whatever informed
choices that you want now unlike you it
turns out i'm not a big drinker it's
just because i've never liked the taste
and i'm surprised that they haven't
taken away my british passport because i
don't like lager or beer
but
i also want to say that life is to be
lived to a certain degree it's all about
checks and balances so you know
if i go out and you know i have an ice
cream sundae i'm not big on those either
but you know sure i know that my you
know blood glucose is not going to be
ideal for another 12 hours maybe that's
just the price you pay for having some
kind of relaxed fun life i don't want to
look back on life
and think gosh you know i lived until i
was you know 111
and it was utterly miserable
you know right so but it's all about
some kind of a balance and
mine my job is not to to tell people um
a prescription for life it's just to
offer some scientific information oh i
think you're doing a terrific job of
that p people are i always say we have
all these neural circuits and um
if it's working properly we all have a
circuit that allows us to skip over
information or as we wish right if the
circuits between your brain and your
thumbs are working you can slide right
along you can drop to the next content
however you like
i i would like to ask about
marijuana and cbd
this is a discussion that i think five
years ago would have ventured into the
realm of illegal but now yeah in many
places not all medical marijuana is
approved or is legal and certainly it's
in
widespread use
certainly not recommending people do it
i have my own thoughts about marijuana
cbd i've been fortunate i suppose that i
don't particularly like marijuana or cbd
i don't even know if i've ever tried cbd
first of all
does marijuana disrupt the depth of
sleep the architecture of sleep
and if so
as with alcohol and caffeine does when
you
ingest it or when it's in your
bloodstream does
relative to when you go to sleep does
that play an important role so does
marijuana disrupt
sleep yeah it it does and
there's a pretty good amount of data on
so we can break uh sort of cannabis down
into two of its key ingredients we've
got thc tetrahydrocannabinol
and we've got cbd and cbd is sort of the
the less psych what's it what we think
of as the non-psychoactive component in
other words when you take cbd you don't
get high if you take thc you can get
high that's the psychoactive part of the
equation are both considered sedatives
in the technical sense uh
no they're not
neither of them have that class right
now
thc can
seems to speed up the time with which
you fall asleep but again if you look at
the the electrical brainwave signature
of your falling asleep with and without
that thc it's not going to
be an ideal fit so you could argue it's
non-natural but many people use thc for
that fact because they find it difficult
to fall asleep and it can speed the
onset of at least non-consciousness i
guess is the best way of describing it
but there are problems with thc
and there are twofold the first is that
it too but through different mechanisms
seems to block rem sleep and that's why
a lot of people when they're using will
tell me look you know i
i definitely i was dreaming i don't
remember you know many of my dreams and
then when they stop using uh thc they'll
say i was having you know just crazy
crazy dreams and the reason is because
there is a rebound mechanism rem sleep
is very clever and alcohol is the same
way in this sense it's the same
homeostatic mechanism some people will
tell me look if i have a bit of a wild
friday night with some alcohol you know
maybe i'll sleep late into the next
morning and i'll just have these really
intense dreams
so and i thought i wasn't having any rem
sleep well the way it works is that it's
during in the middle of the night really
when alcohol blocks your rem sleep
and your brain is smart it understands
how much rem sleep you should have had
how much rem sleep you have not because
the alcohol has been in the system and
finally in those early morning hours
when you're getting through to sort of
you know six seven eight a.m all of a
sudden your brain not only goes back to
having the same amount of rem it would
have had it does that plus it tries to
get back all of the rem sleep that it's
lost does it get back all of the rem
sleep no it doesn't it never gets back
all of the rem sleep but it tries and so
you have these really intense periods of
rem sleep hence you have really intense
bizarre dreams and that's what happens
also with thc you build up this pressure
for rem sleep this debt for rem sleep
will you ever pay it back
it doesn't seem as though you get back
everything that you lost but will you
get back some of it yes the brain will
start to devour more because it's been
starved of rem sleep for so long
but one of the bigger problems with thc
that we worry about is withdrawal
dependency so as you start to use thc
for sleep there can be a
dependency tolerance so you start to
need more to get the same sleep benefit
and when you stop using you usually get
a very severe rebound insomnia and in
fact it's so potent that it's typically
part of the clinical
withdrawal profile from thc from
cannabis
and there's anxiety withdrawal i i've um
i i
you know i don't
ask anybody to change their behavior we
just as you said we try and inform
people about what the science says and
and let them make choices for themselves
people who are regular uh pot smokers if
you that many of will insist they're not
addicted and and maybe indeed they don't
actually follow the profile of classical
addiction i don't know i'm guessing some
do some don't
but
if you ask them well what if i took away
all marijuana consumption
for i don't know two weeks
that thought scares many of them and
many of them will experience intense
anxiety without marijuana which speaks
to perhaps not addiction but a certain
kind of dependency um and again i i you
know i know many pot smokers um some of
whom uh have jobs that are that are
quite high performing and they and they
manage here in berkeley i don't know any
of those
right um
the what about cbd i mean we hear so
much about cbd i've been a little
concerned about the fact that um the
analysis of a lot of cbd supplements out
there is confirmed that much like with
melatonin the levels that are reported
on the labels
in no way shape or form match the levels
that are actually contained in the
various supplements sometimes the levels
are much higher than they're reported on
the labels other times it's much lower
um
what does
ingesting cbd do to the architecture and
quality of sleep
right now i don't think we have enough
data to make some kind of you know
meaningful sense out of it i think the
picture that is emerging however is
probably the following
firstly cbd does not seem to be
detrimental in the same ways that thc is
so we can start by saying it does it
create you know
potential problems
not of the the nature necessarily that
we see with thc
but the devil is a little bit in the
details from the data that we do have
and it comes onto your valid point of
purity
at low dose cbd can seem to be wake
promoting
so in lower doses let's say sort of five
or ten milligrams i'm trying to remember
some of the studies off the top of my
head
there it actually may enhance
wakefulness and cause problems with
sleep
it's only once you get into the higher
dose range that there seem to have been
some you know increases sorry increases
in sleepiness or sort of sedation-like
increases and that's usually i think
above about 25 milligrams
as best i can recall from the data and
then when we look in animal models you
typically see the same type of profile
too
so then the question
becomes and now again you just don't
know about you know purity it's
very difficult although i think
and again i'm i'm not a user not
necessarily because i you know have
anything against it it's just that's not
you know necessarily my cup of tea
there are some firms that are now doing
third party independent laboratory tests
i don't know how gamed that is so i've
got no sense i think some supplement
companies are quite um honest and
accurate about the amounts of various
substances that are in other
uh products and some are not yeah and i
think there's just a huge range i think
the fda is starting to explore cbd there
are i certainly i saw some grant
announcements to explore the function of
cbd most of the work on cbd is being
done by the general public ingesting it
and saying how they feel i gave it to my
dog who was had some uh dementia related
sleep disturbances and it actually
created a heightened wakefulness it
completely straight up sounds as though
he's a bulldog so he's gonna get access
to sleep he's gonna take it okay um
really messed him up took him took it
away he did better um
but you know that's that's a canine so
right and it could have been you know
sort of dose-related too but or binders
or other things that are in there
correct yeah and we
but right now if we were to and i'm not
making this statement i don't think
anyone could make the statement now but
if it ends up being that cbd is
potentially beneficial for sleep
how can we
reconcile that mechanistically and i
think there are
to me at least there are at least three
candidate mechanisms that i've
been exploring and thinking about the
first is that it's thermoregulatory and
what we found in some animal models is
that cbd
will create a profile of hypothermia in
other words it cools the body the core
body temperature down and that's
something that we know is good for sleep
the second is that it's an anxiolytic
that it can reduce anxiety and that data
is actually quite strong even with some
functional imaging work that's been
coming out recently showing that one
epicenter of emotion called the amygdala
deep within the brain is quietened down
with cbd so i think that's at least a
second non-mutant that's great that's
exclusive you know possibility i think
the third um is some recent data that's
come out that was suggesting that cbd
can alter the signaling of adenosine
so it doesn't necessarily mean that you
produce
more adenosine but what it can do is
perhaps modulate the sensitivity perhaps
of the brain so that the weight of that
same adenosine
is
weightier in its brain
signal and therefore it creates this
stronger pressure for sleep so i think
these are all tentative mechanisms i
think any one of them is viable i think
all three are viable together but right
now i think does that sort of help think
through the the tapestry of thc and cbd
yeah very much so and actually it's a
it's a perfect segue from we've talked
about caffeine
alcohol
thc and cbd as sort of uh we framed them
anyway as things that done in moderation
at the appropriate times are probably
okay for most people
certainly not for everybody there will
be differences in sensitivity but that
done at the incorrect times and
certainly in the incorrect amounts will
greatly disrupt this vital stage of life
we call sleep cbd it seems represents a
kind of bridge to the topic i'd like to
talk about next which is
things that promote more healthy sleep
or
somehow contribute to enhancing the
architecture and quality of sleep so i'd
love to chat for a moment about
the kind of grant the original i should
say that not the granddaddy but the og
of sleep supplementation which is
melatonin yeah the so-called hormone of
darkness uh that's inhibited by light
etc
frame for us melatonin
in the context of its naturally
occurring form and then i'd like to talk
about melatonin the supplement because
as in my experience anytime i say the
word melatonin people think about
the supplement melatonin which in itself
is an interesting um
uh phenomenon that people are so cute to
its role as something you take we often
forget that this is something that we
make endogenously i'd love for you to
comment in particular on
even though we without necessarily
getting into precise nanograms per
deciliter values what are the typical
amounts of melatonin that we release
each night and then i'd like to compare
that to what is contained in say a three
milligram or six milligram tablet that
one might buy at the pharmacy right so
i go to sleep at night
has melatonin already kicked in before i
shut my eyes and lay down my head
usually yes if your system is working in
the correct way
as dusk is starting to happen so let's
say that you look at hunter-gatherer
tribes who aren't touched by electricity
and so they're sort of the pure
technical state par excellence when it
comes to electric uh light influence um
and usually it's as dusk is approaching
that's when melatonin will start to rise
and so when you lose the brake pedal of
light coming through the eyes
that normally acts like a hard brake
pedal that stamps down and prevents the
release and production of melatonin as
that light break pedal starts to fade
with dusk then we ease off the brake
pedal and melatonin the spigot of metal
melatonin is opened up and melatonin
starts getting released
and usually we'll see this rising peak
of melatonin um sometime usually an hour
two hours later or around and it varies
from different people around the time of
sleep itself but it's already been on
the march for some hours before
you actually hit sleep itself
interesting and uh i was always taught
and i'm assuming it's still true that
the only source of melatonin in the
brain and body is the pineal gland is
that still true yeah it seems to be from
best that we can tell and the pineal
gland um sort of meaning p like sort of
uh shape it's actually i think usually
people say it's p like i think if you
look at the latin derivative it's more
um i think it's derived from pine cone
not p because in fact if you look at the
pineal it is more pine cone shaped and
so it's aptly named any human brain i've
ever dissected or i confess i've
dissected a lot because i teach
neuroanatomy and have for years um i i
love looking at the pineal it's the one
structure in the brain that's not on
both sides it's usually pretty easy to
find and it's pretty good size it looks
like a it looks like a pea and it's
sitting right there and it's remarkable
that it releases this hormone
probably our entire lifespan and is
inhibited by light the um
so our pineal starts to release this
into the general circulation i have to
imagine we have melatonin receptors in
the brain and body correct so yeah
essentially your brain has a central
master 24-hour clock called the
suprachiasmatic nucleus that keeps
internal time now it's not a precise
clock if left to its own devices nothing
that a swiss clockmaker would be proud
of it runs a little bit long and laggy
it's like an american clock so
there are a couple good american watches
by the way hamilton's are very it's very
much like a boat we're not famous for
our time keeping or our punctuality for
them but the swiss
are it's very it's it's not quite swiss
like it's more berkeley like which is
very relaxed oh you know whatever um so
in most adults of the average adult i
should say your biological clock
normally runs a little bit long it's
about
about 24 hours and 13 minutes i think
was the last calculation
but the reason that we don't keep
drifting forward in time and kind of
running consistently you know more and
later and later 30 minutes by 30 minutes
by 30 minutes each day is because your
central brain clock is regulated by
external things such as daylight and
temperature as well as food and activity
all of these are essentially different
fingers that come along and on the wrist
watch of the 24 hour clock will pull the
dial out and reset it each day to
precisely 24 hours and i make that point
because
it knows 24-hour time
but it needs to tell the rest of the
brain and the body
the 24-hour time as well
and one of the ways that it does this is
by communicating a chemical signal of
24-hour nurse
of light and day
using this hormone melatonin and when it
is at low levels or it's non-existent
it's communicating the message it's
daytime and for us diana's species it
says it's time to be awake
yet
at night time when dusk approaches and
the break comes off melatonin and we
start to release it then it signals to
the rest of the brain and the body look
it's dusk and it's night time and for us
die in all species it's time to think
about sleep so melatonin
essentially
tells the brain and the body when it's
day and when it's night and with that
when it's time to sleep when it's time
to wake and therefore that's why
melatonin helps with the timing
of the onset of sleep but it doesn't
really help with the generation of sleep
itself and this is why we'll come on to
what those studies of supplementation
have taught us
so it tells the rest of my brain and
body it's time to go to sleep it perhaps
even aids with the transition to sleep
but it's not going to for instance
ensure the overall structure of sleep or
um it's not the conductor that's guiding
the sleep orchestra so to speak
throughout the entire night yeah it's
it's more like the um the
people that essentially take you to your
seat and sit you down and give you your
program right exactly yeah sort of the
the the far um less sophisticated
analogy i have is um you know melatonin
is like the starting official at the
hundred meter race in the olympics
that's a better analogy
calls all of the the sleep races to the
line and it begins the great sleep race
yeah better discoloration
coming from the sleep researcher
but it doesn't participate in the race
itself that's a whole different set of
brain chemicals and brain and brain
regions
which
then brings us on to perhaps the
question of supplementation
which is
is it helpful for my sleep will i sleep
longer will i sleep better
and
if i am what doses should i be taking
sadly the evidence in healthy adults who
are not older age
suggests that melatonin is not really
particularly helpful as a sleep aid i
think there was a recent meta-analysis
that demonstrated when um
it it looked at all of the different
sleep parameters melatonin
and a meta-analysis for those not
knowing what that is it's a scientific
sort of method that we use where we
gather all the individual studies and we
put them in a big bucket and we kind of
do this kind of statistical fancy
sleight of hand and we tried to come up
with a big picture of what all of those
individual studies tell us and what that
metro analysis told us is that melatonin
will only increase total amount of sleep
by 3.9 minutes on average minutes
minutes
no and it will only increase your sleep
efficiency by 2.2 percent
so it really is as as uh they say in um
certain parts of california it's weak
sauce that's a weak sauce effect it the
the source is not strong the force is
not strong in in this one when it comes
to
a tool that in healthy people
who are not of older age
it doesn't seem to be especially
beneficial now you know results can vary
everyone is different of course so we're
talking about the average the so-called
average human adult here well melatonin
um in defense of what you're saying and
also i should mention i have a colleague
at stanford uh jamie zeitzer oh
wonderful chuck zeisser's lab at harvard
medway we also trained a terrific sleep
researcher and i asked him about
melatonin and he essentially said the
same thing that you just said which is
very little if any evidence that it can
improve sleep and yet it's probably the
most um commonly consumed so-called
sleep age hundreds of million dollars
industry yeah so
either massive placebo effect or it's
operating through some other mechanism
related to quelling anxiety
yeah that is actually interesting you
know there are some studies where you do
see some you know effects now again when
you do the grand average of all studies
it just doesn't seem to have an effect
but let's assume that for some people it
does have an effect let's not again be
sort of completely dismissive of that
how could it have that effect one of the
reasons that i've become a little bit
more bullish on melatonin from a sleep
perspective and then melatonin more
generally for a
maybe we can speak about this too as a
counter
measure on when you're undergoing
insufficient sleep
um there are two
two different routes there the first
reason that i think it could have a
sleep benefit for some people is not
because it helps in the generation of
sleep we know that it doesn't it's
because it too seems to drop core body
temperature
there it is
again i'm fascinated these days more and
more by temperature as um
maybe not just a refl a reflection of
brain state and wakefulness and in sleep
but actually a lever that uh is quite
powerful i think it's both and with all
the interest in ice baths and hot
showers and saunas and stuff something
that we will definitely touch on
temperature variation is so key so if if
melatonin is dropping body temperature
by a degree or so something that you've
said before can help induce a sleepy
state
maybe that's what's allowing people to
get it and that's one possibility i i
don't think melatonin by itself will
drop it by sort of you know a a degree
certainly not a degree celsius and for
order in us to fall asleep and then stay
asleep across the night we do need to
drop our core body temperature by about
one degree celsius or about two to three
degrees fahrenheit and that's why it's
always easier to fall asleep in a room
that's too cold than too hot
i think that that's one potential avenue
that we are considering thinking more
deeply about when it comes to melatonin
and then the other is melatonin as an
antioxidant but let's
let me table that for now because i'll
just get us sidetracked
that's what we know so far about
melatonin
in terms of its supplementation benefit
or lack thereof
two final points that i shouldn't forget
one is
the only population where we typically
see some benefit and it often is
prescribed is in older adults because
older meaning
60 and older yeah 60 65 and older
because as we get older you can
typically have what's called
calcification of the pineal gland which
means that that gland that's releasing
melatonin doesn't work as well anymore
as a consequence they tend to have a
flatter overall curve of melatonin
released throughout the night it's not
this beautiful lovely peak and this
bullhorn message of it's darkness please
get to sleep that's why older adults can
have problems falling asleep or staying
asleep it's not the only reason by sure
any stretch of the imagination but it's
one of the reasons and it's why
melatonin supplementation in those
cohorts older adults especially older
adults with insomnia people have thought
about that as maybe an appropriate use
case
along those lines if we were to compare
dosages
i don't or do we know how much melatonin
is typically released into the
bloodstream per night um and can we use
that as a kind of a rule of thumb by
which to compare the typical amount that
someone would supplement i mean
typically the supplements for melatonin
that i see
in the pharmacy and elsewhere and online
range anywhere from one milligram to 12
or even 20 milligrams
my guess is that a normal night's
release of melatonin typical for
somebody in their 20s 30s 40s
would be far lower than that am i
correct or wrong yeah it's it's a many
magnitudes lower and this is one of the
problems is that i see that too i see
you know typical doses are you know five
milligrams or 10 milligrams and of
course you know if you're a supplement
company you know putting 10 milligrams
versus 5 milligrams if that's what
you're actually doing which we'll speak
about purity as well
um
you know it's kind of like the super
gulp size
nobody wants to lower price
they just want you to you know we'll
just give you more for the same price
and that's how we'll compete so it's
been this escalating arms race of
melatonin concentration and it really
does not look meaningful for
you know for sleep in any way
what we've actually found is that the
optimal doses for where you do get sleep
benefits in the populations that we've
looked at are somewhere between
0.1 and 0.3
milligrams of melatonin in other words
the typical doses are usually
10 times 20 times maybe more
than
what your body would naturally expect
and this is what we call a
supraphysiological dose in other words
it's far above what is physiologically
normal
you know and to put that in context
imagine i said to you i want you to eat
20 times as much food today i thought
you're going to use testosterone as an
example
you're going to take 300 times the
normal amount of testosterone we know
that would have um
tons of deleterious effects very
terrible yeah and yet you can do this
what one thing that i'm concerned about
about these supraphysiological levels of
melatonin is that many years ago
actually here at berkeley when i was a
graduate student we would inject
animals which were seasonally breeding
animals with melatonin and
the consequence of that was that their
uh gonads either their testes or ovaries
would shrink many hundred hundred fold
or more um in other words they would go
from having
nice healthy sized hamster testicles
what a hamster would consider healthy
size um for a hamster and they would
shrink to the size of a grain of rice so
from like an almonds to a grain size of
a grain of rice i had to see that only
once for me to be very concerned about
super physiological levels of melatonin
and i realized that melatonin does
different things in different species we
are not hamsters we are not seasonal
breeders
uh seasonally restricted breeders there
might be more breeding during certain
seasons i don't know those data but
nonetheless
hormones are powerful and and sure there
is an optimal and sometimes uh we see
that going slightly above endogenous
levels for certain hormones not always
can have beneficial effects and
sometimes it can have detrimental
effects i'm just concerned about taking
high levels of a hormone
that
has effects on the reproductive axis and
that's one of the reasons why i get very
concerned when i see people
really getting aggressive about
melatonin supplementation taking a
hundred ten five hundred sometimes even
ten thousand times the amount that we
would normally release that's that's my
concern although it's not nested in any
one specific human study i just i just
don't like to see
i certainly don't want to see other
people and i don't want to
personally take a hormone that's known
to be androgen suppressive
at high levels why would i why would i
take that right that's the question i
ask myself i think it's a very you know
good point and
if you look at
some of the evidence around you know
melatonin's lethality if you want to go
to that extreme for the most part you
know it it's pretty safe that you mean
you can take a lot of it before you die
right exactly yeah but i don't know that
that's that's not going to be your
yardstick because you know you really
need to think about your you know your
health not just whether this thing is
going to to kill you or not as the
decision matrix through which you
pop a pill
and it comes on to this concern around
melatonin because there was a study
i think it's one that you mentioned too
where they looked at over i think it was
at least over 20 different brands of
melatonin supplements and what they
found is that based on what it said on
the bottle versus what was in the
capsules themselves it ranged from i
think it was 83 percent less than what
it said on the bottle to
more than what it said on the bottle
now if you're if that's a 10 milligram
you know pill and it's
more than 10 milligrams and we're
already at 10 milligrams at many tens of
times more than is a physiological
rather than a supra physiological dose
yeah we do need to be a bit thoughtful
yeah remember those hamsters folks
uh well and i do
appreciate the deep dive on melatonin
because i think people
need to understand that it's it's
nuanced it's a matter of dosages and
timing etc and then it may have its
place as you mentioned in older
individuals
and i should mention that i i'm an avid
consumer of supplements that i believe
in for me and i have been for a very
long time so i'm by no means
anti-supplement um some supplements i
refuse to take or avoid taking others i
am uh quite avidly take and
along those lines
i personally uh
and i don't know uh what your thoughts
on this are but now there are a few
things that i've personally found
beneficial i'd love your thoughts on
them and i would love it if you would
tell me that uh everything i'm about to
refer to as placebo that would be fine
so um that's what we do we're scientists
we argue and then and then we um we
remain friends in uh as it goes
so um magnesium
there are many forms of magnesium
magnesium citrate is a as we know is a
terrific laxative uh magnesium malate
seems
at least from a few studies seems to
relieve some of delayed onset muscle
soreness doesn't seem to create a kind
of sedation two forms of magnesium that
i'm aware of magnesium by glycinate and
magnesium three and eight yeah
we believe based on the data can more
actively cross the blood-brain barrier
so you put in your gut but some of that
needs to get into your brain in order to
have the sedative effect
what are your thoughts on magnesium
supplementation do you supplement with
magnesium
and um
what what studies would you like to see
done if they haven't been done already
so i don't supplement with magnesium
but i do think threon8 is interesting
because of that higher capacity to cross
the brain barrier and actually have a
central nervous system effect and the
reason that that interests me is because
the sleep is by the brain of the brain
and also for the brain as well as for
the body
we just don't have a particularly good
set of studies that have targeted
exclusively three and eight we do have
lots of studies that have just looked at
magnesium in general for sleep and
overall the data is uncompelling
interesting and
for a while
i i was confused as to why
where did this come from this kind of
myth of magnesium so i started looking
back into the literature and
i've best traced it at least as far as i
can tell
to early studies showing that those who
are deficient in magnesium also had
sleep problems they had other problems
too of course but sleep problems were
one of that set of sequelae that came
from having lower magnesium and when
they
supplemented with magnesium and tried to
restore those levels some of those sleep
problems dissipated
and then that seems to have gotten lost
in sort of some game of sort of like
whispers around the room and it's become
translated into people who don't have
sleep problems who are healthy sleepers
and who are healthy in general and who
have healthy normal levels of magnesium
if they take more magnesium they will
sleep better
and the data really there is not good
once again the only study that i've seen
where magnesium did have some efficacy
was in a study with older adults i think
they were 60 to 80 years old it may have
been exclusively women now i think about
it and they also had insomnia and in
that population you did see some
benefits and my guess is that because
it's an older
community as well they were probably
probably deficient in magnesium so they
fit the former category of simply when
you're deficient and you restore you can
help sleep sort of return to normal but
if you are not deficient and you're
healthy and you're not old and you don't
have insomnia and you're supplementing
thinking that it provides sleep right
now the data isn't supportive of that
but i just don't think we have enough
three and eight data to actually speak
about that because it could just be a
blood-brain barrier issue so far with
the other forms so maybe some additional
studies looking specifically at three
and eight or by glycinate would be would
be unless we have magnesium's involved
in so many cellular processes you can
imagine that this effect if it truly
exists is uh as we say in science in the
noise meaning it's in the it's in the
the jitter of the data but to isolate
the real effect one needs to do some
more refined studies um
what are some things that are
of interest to you if not things that
you happen to take um
these are not things that i personally
take mostly because i just haven't
experimented with them valerian root
is one um
tart cherry and kiwi fruit
tell me about tell me about valerian
root tart cherry and kiwi fruit this is
new to me um i've certainly heard of
them and um tart cherry and kiwi sounds
delicious
but what
what's happening with valerian root tart
cherry and kiwi and are we talking about
eating tart cherries and kiwis and
valerian roots you're talking about
taking them in pill form usually it's
supplements but it's also both for tart
cherries and for kiwis it's the actual
you know fruit themselves
valerian often touted as a beneficial
sleep aid and lots of people swear by it
too but the evidence is actually quite
against that oh really not that it makes
your sleep worse but
of at least the seven good studies that
i've been able to find and typically
these are of the nature of what we call
a randomized placebo crossover design
and i won't bore people with what that
means it's sort of one of the studies
yeah it's one of the sort of gold
standard methods that we have when we're
looking at intervention studies such as
drug cities
five of the seven found no benefit uh a
valerian root on sleep then two out of
the seven
the data was just insufficient i think
it was a power issue where they just
couldn't make any strong conclusions
and then i think there was the most
recent
study
i think looked at
two different doses
of valerian i could have this wrong and
they just failed to find any effects
once again but the stunning part of that
paper as i recall they had this big
table with all of the different sleep
metrics that they looked at and there
were well over 25 different things that
they tried to see if valerian impacted
and none of them were significant which
stuns me because from statistical
probabilities we know if you just
randomly perform 25 statistical tests
chances are probabilistically you'll
just get one significant result by
random chance and even with random
chance on their side
they still couldn't find a benefit of
valerian so so valerian root might be
worse than nothing at all if there is uh
so to speak i mean again placebo effect
we can think about that too and i would
say that if you feel as though it's
having a benefit for you and with all of
the caveats that we have with
supplements things like melatonin purity
concentration etc
you know maybe it's no harm no foul but
i'm not a you know a medical doctor and
i don't tell anyone about we have all of
these disclaimers about not
recommendations and we'll include these
things i mean i always say you know
we're not physicians we don't prescribe
anything we're scientists and professors
so we profess things it's up to people
to be responsible for their own health
not just to protect us but to protect
themselves um
i i do want to hear about tart cherry
kiwi fruit um
what what's the story there strange
isn't it i was
you know i i'm kind of a hard-nosed
scientist and when people you know some
years ago started saying oh tart
cherries it's the thing or kiwi fruits i
was thinking
oh my goodness this sounds good in
california
yeah i know yeah the sun has softened me
uh some but i thought look one of the
things that we have to do as scientists
is be as open-minded as possible and i
should not be so quick to dismiss so i
went to the literatures just started
reading as much as i could about it
and there were three really good
randomized placebo crossover trials with
tart cherries
and what they found was that in one
study it reduced the amount of time that
you spent awake at night by over an hour
and then the other two studies one of
them found that it increased the amount
of sleep that you got by 34 minutes the
other it increased the amount of sleep
that you got by 84 minutes wow which you
know these are and what's striking is
that they were independent uh studies i
think meaning that they were from
independent groups and these were you
know some of these guys you know i i and
girls i know
pretty well mm-hmm
you know and trust their work right i
really trust their work too are they
ingesting actual tart cherries or
they're drinking the juice or in capsule
it was juice so they in all three
studies it was juice
although you can i think as a supplement
you can buy it in a capsule and we've
got no idea whether that changes the
benefit or not
what was also interesting in i think it
was that last study where they got an
increase in sleep by 84 minutes
it also decreased daytime napping
significantly that's one that i could
certainly make use of so i'm i love you
you know but i'd love to skip them too
right and we can speak about naps and
such of the upside and downside of that
which then made me think well if that's
the case maybe the net net benefit on
sleep overall is no different it's just
that it decreases the amount of time
that some people were taking to sleep
during the day and giving it back to the
night but that wasn't the case because
if you added the total amount of sleep
that they were getting without tart
cherries both naps and nightly sleep
combined
still when you took tart cherries you
still got to net some benefits total
amount of sleep so
you know so far
when it comes to supplements and those
types of studies they're good studies
and the data looks interesting but as a
drug itself you know if this was
clinical drug you know three studies
that are somewhat small in nature and
have some positive benefit that's what
we would call preliminary data of maybe
a chin scratching kind so yeah and
depending on the margins for safety one
might think well
given that it's a tart cherry as opposed
to some pharmaceutical you need a
prescription for then uh you know some
people their threshold to experiment
with supplements is quite low some
people their threshold is quite high i
feel like you know there are two
categories or at least two categories of
folks out there people who hear oh tart
cherry can improve sleep and we'll run
out and try it and people who hear well
that sounds crazy why would i do that um
but of course we have to remind people
that tart cherry isn't really what we're
talking about presumably if this is a
real effect and sounds like it might be
that there's a compound in tart cherry
that's right that if we were to call it
whatever whatever five alpha six
you know some molecule if we refer to it
by its technical name then people would
say oh that sounds like a very
interesting technical way to approach
sleep but doesn't sound very natural so
both groups are a little bit um
misguided
in the sense that people who think that
everything that comes from naturally
occurring foods plants etc things that
grow out of the ground that that's all
safe that's not true and people that
think that pharmaceuticals are the only
if it's not evidence with the purified
molecule then something's not of utility
well that's certainly not true somewhere
in the middle i think lies the answer
which is
sounds to me like tart cherry is at
least
an intriguing
potential sleep aid intriguing potential
sleep aid and underscoring potential um
i'm certainly intrigued by it to the
point where i i might experiment a bit
but i'm an experimenter for myself um
before i uh ask you about kiwi
uh i've had quite good results from
taking something called apogenin which
is a derivative of chamomile
but in supplement form i think i take 50
milligrams about 30 minutes before sleep
and i subjectively experience a
a better night's sleep so to speak i
don't measure i confess i don't measure
my sleep i'm not a sleep tracker guy um
but uh
you know there are a few papers out
there they're not what we would call
blue published in blue ribbon journals
but but they have control groups and it
looks somewhat interesting and there
when i say apogenin uh people get
somewhat intrigued oh this molecule
chamomile has long been thought to be a
sedative a mild sedative but a sedative
do you drink chamomile tea do you take
apogenin what are your thoughts on
epigenetics yeah i i don't and i i have
looked into some of the data regarding
sleep as well right now from best i can
tell it's mostly subjective data rather
than objective hard sort of sleep
measures and that's why right now i you
know it's sort of
unclear
not no comment but just unclear
not dismissing it because i think you
and i both ascribe to the idea of
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence so keep your mind open at least
i tell that to myself
[Music]
i think if you're finding a benefit and
you can do what i would think of if i
was personally experimenting which is
both the positive and negative
parts of the experiment what i mean by
that is you know let's say that i now
want to you know think about some kind
of a sleep supplement i will take some
kind of baseline set of recordings for a
month
and i will just gauge where i'm at
sort of supplement free
then i'll go on for a month
to whatever i'm thinking of taking and i
don't you know supplement but let's say
that i want to and i experiment with
that
and i feel as though based on my metrics
be them objective from my aura ring or
be them subjective from whatever i'm you
know writing down in the morning and
both are important valid subjective and
objective we like both in the sleep
world
and i think okay look it's clearly that
it seems to have some kind of an effect
the key thing however is then do the
negative experiment which is now come
off it for another month and see do
things get worse and if i can see that
bi-directionality
then i am starting to think
maybe i'm believing this a little bit
more so that's the way i would sort of
typically approach you know a
supplementation regiment if i were to do
it and that's just me that's just the
way my mind works but no that's great i
think it's very very scientific and
organized in a way that allows uh you
and and would allow other people to make
very informed decisions for themselves
um i like that i um i like to think in
terms of of manipulating any aspect of
our biology that behavioral tools always
are the first line of entry
then
nutrition everyone has to eat sooner or
later even if you're fasting
then perhaps supplementation then
prescription drugs and then perhaps
brain machine interface devices that you
use to induce something and those could
be done in combination but what concerns
me is when i hear people
say well
what should i take without thinking
about their behavior their light viewing
behavior et cetera but of course these
things work in combination uh i think
it's you're right that there's many when
it comes to sleep there are many
low-hanging fruits
that don't necessarily require you to
you know put
sort of exogenous molecules in other
words things like supplements into your
body or you know use different types of
drugs to help you get there now when it
comes to prescription sleep aids
i think i've been again a little bit too
forthright
we know in clinical practice that there
may be a time and a place for things
like sleeping pills they are a
short-term solution to certain forms of
insomnia but they are not recommended
for the long term and we also know that
there are lots of other ways that you
can get a sleep
help or you can get a sleep curative
profile from things like cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia which is
a non-drug approach psychologically
quite effective from what i understand
just as effective as sleeping pills
great data more effective in the long
term there's a recent study published
that after working with that therapist
some of the benefits lasted almost a
decade
you know now if you stop sleeping pills
usually you have rebound insomnia where
your sleep goes back to being just as
bad if not worse
and i think the same is true when we
think about supplementation there are so
many things that are easy to implement
when it comes to sleep that don't
require venturing out into those waters
and again
we're not here to tell anyone about
whether they should venture or not
that's completely your choice all i'm
saying is that if you want to think
about optimizing your sleep there are a
number of ways that you can do it that
don't necessarily require you to swallow
and think or inject anything called you
know smoke anything or right and for
which the margins of safety are quite
quite wide right that's that's the other
one yes sorry so speaking of low-hanging
fruit i don't know how low it hangs in
reality but what what about kiwi they're
delicious to me anyway yeah the humble
kiwi fruit um
named not um shouldn't be mistaken for
the the the um flightless bird of uh new
zealand which is the native bird that
we're talking about the kiwi the fruit
here which um those trees and shrubs are
um mostly um south east asia
kiwi fruits have been previously touted
as potentially having a sleep benefit
which again got me curious and i at
first threw it out
to my knowledge there's really only one
published human study that's of any
value but
what they did find was that it decreased
the speed of time with which it took you
to fall asleep these are you ingesting
the whole kiwi so it's ingesting the
whole thing with the skin
skin people cringe when they see me well
i don't eat this no no no i think the
idea is some of the good stuff and i'll
come on to this may actually be in the
skin it's oneself thank you you just you
i just want you just help me win a bet
i'll give you your okay okay yeah you
can familiarize by the way this skin is
used no no he just told me to say that
so he went no he did not um
so the skin seems to be part of this
potential sleep equation
and that's the d yeah they um
you fell asleep faster and you stayed
asleep for longer and you spent less
time awake throughout the night
and i just thought well you know that's
one study what can you really do with
that
there is another study however in an
animal model which is you know a little
bit more interesting
and once again they found a very similar
phenotype that the rats oh sorry they
were mice the mice fell asleep faster
and they also spent longer time in sleep
the sleep duration also increased what
was also interesting mechanistically and
this is not the mechanism that i think
ties together
tart cherries kiwi fruit and you know
things like melatonin because i think
there could be one common binding
mechanism what they found in the animal
study is that they could block those
kiwi fruit sleep benefits using a gaba
blocking agent now gaba
gaba which stands for gamma amino
butyric acid is one of the major
inhibitory neurotransmitters of the
brain it's kind of like they're actually
occurring sedative right sort of yeah
it's the kind of the red light on the
traffic light signal you know um others
are green light um gaba is red light
so by playing around with some sort of
clever drugs to manipulate the system
they could prevent the benefit of the
kiwi fruit by
sort of buggering around with the gaba
receptor meaning that perhaps part of
the kiwi fruit benefit on sleep was
mediated by the brain's natural
inhibitory neurotransmitter system
called the gaba system and i thought
that was that was kind of in that
convinced me a little bit more that
maybe there's something here to read
into so
to be determined again here is the
banner
but it you know tart cherries and kiwi
fruits the data surprised me
because in part i was
so preoccupied with
being you know
i don't know
a bit pureish about in a bit snobby
thinking though come on
that's definitely not going to work well
i look forward to a day when supplements
are no longer called supplements because
at the end of the day whether or not
something has an effect whether or not
it's a whole kiwi fruit or a derivative
kiwi fruit will depend on the molecular
compound and as you mentioned this
potential mechanism via the gaba system
um
that's like we both as scientists get
excited about mechanism because when you
can trace a mechanism in a pathway it
provides a rationale a grounding for why
kiwi of all things or tart cherry of all
things might help
increase total sleep time
uh
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention or ask
about
tryptophan and serotonin i can totally
say
when i've taken tryptophan
the precursor to serotonin or serotonin
itself
i have a horrendous night's sleep i fall
asleep very easily
and i experience
ridiculously vivid dreams
neither pleasant nor unpleasant is kind
of a mishmash and then i wake up and i
experience several days of insomnia that
and i've done the
the positive control and the negative
control and all the variations thereof
to confirm that at least for me
supplementing with serotonergic agents
is a bad idea for me
and um tryptophan is a common
sleep supplement and sleep aid that's
discussed
the normal architecture of sleep
involves the release of serotonin but in
a very timed and regulated way what are
your thoughts about serotonin in sleep
if you had to kind of put that into a
nutshell and then
why
supplementing sup with serotonin and or
its precursor
tryptophan might be a good or a bad idea
for somebody
i think one of the
potential dangers is that
based on what's going on in your body
that can change the absorption of
natural
sort of tryptophan and serotonin uptake
within the brain itself
so i'm always
thoughtful when you're playing around
with that mother nature dynamic as it
were
the data as you described is a little
bit all over the map some people say
that it knocks them out other people say
just like you do it has a terrible
impact on my sleep and when i stop it
it's pretty bad for a couple of days it
seems to have this lingering after
effect
i think what could be happening here is
we need serotonin to just as you
described be modulated in very specific
ways during the different stages of
sleep if you look at the firing of the
brain epicenters where serotonin is
released and there's a bunch of them in
the brain stem
what you find on the release of of
serotonin 2 when we're awake it's
usually in high concentrations as we
start to drift off to sleep it lowers
some but not necessarily dramatically as
we're going into non-rem sleep but then
when we go into rem sleep
serotonin is shut off
the other one of the other
neuromodulators noradrenaline also shut
off
rem sleep is the only time during the 24
hour period where we see noradrenaline
and serotonin or norepinephrine
completely shut down when i say
serotonin we're also talking 5-htp sorry
5-ht that's just its chemical name here
so
whether it
speaking about serotonin 5ht it's the
same thing norepinephrine noradrenaline
both of those need to be shut down for
you to produce rem sleep the other one
of the other neuromodulators that then
ramps up to produce rem sleep is
acetylcholine
so these three neuromodulators have this
incredible reciprocal dance that they
have for you to generate what is called
a natural architecture of sleep
throughout the night it's the push-pull
again it's a push pull again you know
it's you know it's
chest and back it's you know whatever
you want to think of
that's why i think if you're trying to
increase
dramatically drive up your serotonin
levels at night and that sustains
throughout the night when you're trying
to get into rem sleep you could be
artificially fragmenting rem sleep now i
don't know the data i don't think
anyone's really got no good data but
that's why i would be
you know if you were to say
matt two years time that's the data help
me understand the potential mechanism or
let's design some experiments where
would you go first i would say let's
look at the disruption of rem sleep
non-rem sleep reciprocal regulation
because
you know you need serotonin to be you
know up at one time down at another
so i i um agree with everything you said
and i'm um i'm personally never taking
tryptophan or serotonin again unless
there's some clinical reason for that
that i would need to do that i want to
ask about um some other pro-sleep
behaviors
but before i do that
let's talk about naps i love naps i come
from a long history of nappers uh my dad
always took a nap in the afternoon i
take a 20 or 30 minute nap or i do a
practice which i um took the liberty of
coining nsdr non-sleep depressed some
sort of just passive laying
out their feet up elevated sometimes
people do you or i'll do yoga nidra i'll
do hypnosis or something of that sort
but
20 or 30 minutes
of that has been very beneficial for me
to get up from that
nap or
period of
minimal wakefulness we'll call it and go
about my day quite well and also fall
asleep just fine
what are the data on naps uh do you nap
and what are your thoughts about keeping
nap short meaning 20 to 30 minutes
versus getting out past 90 minutes two
hours so uh for you personally naps yay
nay or meh i don't nap um and i've just
never been a habitual nappa is that
because you don't feel sleepy in the
afternoon or because we don't feel
sleepy you're just heartier than i am i
wouldn't say hardier i may be um
less capable of falling asleep um but
nicely dry afternoon no no i don't drink
so you don't nap because you don't feel
a need to nap that's right yep now it's
not that i am immune to what we call a
postprandial dip in alertness i
definitely feel as though there can be
this kind of ethanol afternoon lull
where you know i'm not quite as on as i
was at 11 o'clock in the morning and we
know the physiology to that which brings
us back to whether we were designed to
nap so for naps we've done lots of
different studies and other colleagues
have done these studies too naps can
have some really great benefits we found
benefits for cardiovascular health blood
pressure for example we found benefits
for levels of cortisol we found benefits
for learning in memory and also
emotional regulation
how long are the naps typically in those
studies anywhere between 20 minutes to
90 minutes sometimes we like to use a 90
minute window so that the participant
can have a full cycle of sleep and
therefore they get both non-rem and rem
sleep within that time period then when
we wake them up we usually wait a period
of time to get them past what we call
sleep inertia which is that kind of
window of grogginess where you say to
your better half look you know darling
please don't
speak to me for the first hour after
i've done anything right now after the
first hour of waking up you know i'm not
just i'm just not the best version of
myself
so we wait for that time period and then
we do some testing and we've done some
testing before and after and we look at
the change and that's how we measure
what was the benefit of naps and the
reason why we sometimes do 90 minutes so
that they get all of those stages of
sleep and then we correlate
how much benefit did you get from the
nap and how much of that benefit was
explained by what rem sleep you got what
deep sleep you got what light sleep you
got so that's the only reason that we
use that as an experimental tool
what we've also found is that naps
of as little as 17 minutes can have some
quite potent effects on for example
learning
none of this is novel
nasa pioneered this back in the 1990s
and during the missions they were
experimenting with naps for their
astronauts and what they found was that
naps of little as 26 minutes
improved um
mission performance by 34
and improved daytime alertness by 50
percent
and it birthed what was then called the
nasa nap culture throughout all
terrestrial nasa staff during that time
period so it's long been known that naps
can have a benefit
naps however can have a double-edged
sword there is a dark side to naps
and it comes back to our story of
adenosine and sleep pressure the longer
we're awake the more of that sleep
pressure adenosine that we build up but
what i didn't tell you is that when we
sleep
the brain gets the chance to essentially
clear out that adenosine
and after about 16 hours of wakefulness
and then after about eight hours of
sleep eight hours of sleep seems to be
able to
allow the brain to decrease its
adenosine levels back to normal and so
naturally we should start to wake up
which also aligns with your circadian
rhythm and those are two separate
processes but
with about eight hours of good quality
sleep seven to nine hours for the
average adult we are free of all of that
adenosine we've evacuated it essentially
out of the brain and we wake up
naturally feeling refreshed
the reason that naps can be potentially
dangerous is that when you nap
you are essentially opening the valve on
the pressure cooker of sleep pressure
and some of that
sleepiness is lost by way of the nap so
for some people and not all people and
you're a great example of this
some people however if they are
struggling with sleep at night and they
nap during the day it makes their sleep
problems even worse so for people with
insomnia we typically advise against
napping
and the advice is if you can nap
regularly and you don't struggle with
sleep at night then naps are just fine
but if you do struggle with sleep stay
away from naps if you are going to nap
try to limit your naps try to cut them
off a bit like sort of caffeine maybe
you know eight to sort of 12 hours maybe
not that you know far off maybe sort of
seven to six hours is a good rule of
thumb try not to nap essentially late in
the afternoon and if you do take a nap
and you want to maintain your
you don't want to have that grogginess
hangover that can happen after a full
night of sleep for the first hour try to
limit it to about 20 25 minutes and that
way you don't go down into the very
deepest stages of sleep which i if i
wrench you out of with an alarm then you
just kind of feel you almost feel worse
for the first hour after the nap i've
definitely experienced that if i over
sleep certainly if uh the sun goes down
during my nap and i wake up and light
overall lighting conditions have changed
i find it very hard to jolt myself back
into the evening and it can screw me up
so i try and keep those naps pretty
brief and i should say um
i i'm very happy to hear you mention
individual differences and why some
people might want a nap and other people
might not want to nap uh i have a
colleague leech and low he'll be
familiar to many neurobiologists who's a
absolutely spectacular scientist um
member of the national academy howard
hughes investigator just a phenom and uh
has a ton of energy but years ago i
learned that he always takes a nap in
the afternoon so much so that when he
travels to give seminars at other
universities he will tell his post lunch
um
host whoever it is that he's supposed to
meet with may i have your office for 30
minutes of our sometimes 30-minute
discussion or 60-minute discussion
because i like to take a nap and he does
that and then gives his his talks are
typically in the afternoon in academic
culture
and
he
describes the the effect of the nap for
him the short naps in the afternoon
being so profound for his productivity
that's actually what inspired me to
start feeling okay about my desire to
nap yeah and so i think uh for me that
was great vindication for
those that might feel guilty about
wanting a nap but i i take to heart your
note about um
avoiding naps if you have trouble
falling and staying asleep because i
think that they i know i have family
members who also if they nap they're a
wreck they can't sleep yeah i think it's
just
we've often been very pro sleep we as
the sort of the sleep community so i
think it's good to always point out
these potential dark sides of of any
aspect but you're absolutely right no
one should feel guilty about getting the
sleep that they need
and i think that's been one of the big
problems in society society has
stigmatized sleep with these labels of
being slothful or lazy and we're almost
embarrassed you know to tell colleagues
that we we take a nap i think
sleep is a right of human beings and i
therefore think that sleep is a civil
right of all human beings and no one
should make you feel unproud of getting
the sleep that you need no i i love that
and i it's an important point um i also
feel that one of the best ways to um
beat your competition in any endeavor is
to outlive them
so and now that we know that sleep can
enhance uh longevity and lack of sleep
can shorten one's life um that's all the
justification i need anyway
can
somebody sleep too much is it possible
to get too much sleep
it's a very good question and there are
probably two things to say about it
there is a condition that we call
hypersomnia
but that's a mixture of things it's
where people have either a very high
sleep need or they are very sleepy
during the day and they're typically
falling asleep and these can happen in a
variety of different clinical contexts
one of the places where we've often seen
hypersomnia believed to manifest is in
depression
but if you look at some of those studies
it turns out it looks more as though
those people are simply reporting being
in bed longer but not necessarily
sleeping longer and that fits very well
with one of the profiles that we know of
depression which is anadonia you don't
get pleasure from normally pleasurable
things so you just don't want to go out
into the world you don't want to
interact because you're depressed so
what do you do you just stay in bed
blind clothes watching tv right and that
just looks as though you know when
people say
what time did you go to bed and what
time did you get out of bed
the mistake made in that question is
okay that's how much time they're
sleeping when you should have said what
time did you fall asleep and what time
did you wake up and the answer could be
very different
so
that's hyposomnia from a clinical
context
can you sleep too much though one of the
data points that argues yes that's
possible is when we look at all-cause
mortality
certainly what you find is that using
the sweet spot of seven to nine hours
when you start to drop below seven hours
there is a relationship which suggests
that the shorter your sleep the shorter
your life short sleep in that regard
predicts all cause mortality but it's
again not a linear relationship like the
one that we've seen with rem sleep once
you get past nine hours the mortality
curve stops going down and then once you
get further 10 11 hours it hooks back up
again it's almost like a j shape tilted
over a little bit and reversed
so there's this strange hook what's
going on here
right now
sleep science has at least two
non-mutually exclusive explanations for
this the first is that if you look at
some of those populations
the idea is that
the whatever was causing them illness
and took their lives
was just too much for sleep to deal with
however we know that when we get sick
one of the things that we do immediately
in this whole mechanism an inflammatory
mechanism cytokine mediated when we get
sick we want to sleep more we just want
to kill up in bed and you know sleep it
sleep it off
so
the argument there is that it's not that
sleep was killing people prematurely it
was that these people were calling on
this the help of sleep they were calling
on this thing called the swiss army
knife of health that is sleep
but whatever it is that they were facing
was just too powerful
for sleep to overcome so it artificially
looks as though more sleep leads to a
higher risk of death when sleep was
actually responding to the mortality
risk and it lost the battle that's one
argument the second is that we know that
sleep quality and poor sleep efficiency
is a very strong predictor of all-cause
mortality and when you look at people
who often report sleeping long amounts
10 or 11 hours they typically report
having very poor quality sleep so
because their quality of sleep is poor
they just try to sleep longer to try and
get some of that back
so again here now it's poor quality
sleep masking as
too much sleep leading to this
artificial huck which looks like
mortality that's a second explanation
a third which is more of a duncan which
is just kind of like a thought
experiment and i'm of this mentality i
don't know how many other people share
this
i actually think there could be a thing
as too much sleep
physiologically i think it's possible
but the reason i think that is because
it's no different than food water or
oxygen can you overeat yes you can can
you under eat of course
light in the early part of the day
throughout the day wonderful light late
in the day right at night detrimental
bi-directional you know
for water can you over hydrate hyper
neutrino it can lead you know it
happened in the 1990s and 2000 with the
ecstasy craze where governments were
saying you're dehydrating you're dancing
all night please drink water and they
drank too much water their blood
electrolytes went you know all over the
place and they were having cardiac
arrests or stroke yeah people were dying
and they were dying because of excessive
hydration can you get too much oxygen
hyperoxemia and it can cause free
radical damage which can be
profoundly harmful and kill brain cells
can you sleep too much you know which is
the fifth element of the life equation
you know alongside you know
food water oxygen um you know so
forth i should say you can't even count
clearly i'm sleeping well um
yes i think there could be that
possibility are most people in danger of
getting too much sleep
oh contra if you look at the data right
so yeah but i i don't dismiss that idea
i think it's it's possible
it's that's a very thorough and very
nuanced and yeah very clear answer so i
i
um it's so interesting to think that a
lot of the
the data that out there that talking
about
being in bed too long that it's just
trying to compensate for the actual
fragmentation of sleep so
what i'm coming away with is that there
are many paths to this and uh both
positive and things to avoid but the
idea is to get
most nights a
similar amount probably seven to nine
hours somewhere in there of
high quality sleep that this notion of
sleep quality is going to become
i would hope uh a phrase that more
people think about and learn about and
cultivate as a practice
i want to ask about a set of behaviors
that i'm at least
i'm aware of at least one company is
starting to track in their sleep
monitoring device and that's um
orgasm
and
sex orgasm and masturbation topics that
are
you know are somewhat um
sensitive um
but from the perspective of biology
right
none of us would be here we're not for
uh sperm meats egg in some fashion
either in a dish or or in vivo um but
what
what are the data as as you know them to
be or maybe your labs even doing this
kind of um work and exploration about
the role that
sex
orgasm masturbation play in getting to
sleep and staying asleep and sleep
quality certainly those behaviors and
those physiological events have been
part of our evolutionary history right
um
what's the story there what can we say
about this in in terms of um science and
and
dare i say practice
yeah i mean it's almost that caricature
of you know in the movies where you know
a couple makes love and then all of a
sudden you just sort of hear snoring or
you know it happens
with the idea that it's somewhat
somnogenic that it's sleep promoting
well the orgasmic increase in prolactin
well that's is is is interesting ought
to be a set a naturally occurring
sedative that presumably has a function
in and oxytocin has that also that
benefit where you see you know a
dissipation of the fight or flight
branch of the nervous system which has
to happen for you to fall asleep that's
why we often see you know here at the
sleep center we'll see a phenomenon
called
wired and tired where people say look i
am so desperately tired i am i just i'm
so so tired but i can't fall asleep
because i'm too wired so your sleep
drive you're you're desperately tired
it's there but because you're wired
because you've got too much sympathetic
activation too much cortisol as well you
can't fall asleep it's a it's an
impressive
roadblock to anything like good sleep
and it's one of the principal mechanisms
that we now believe stress and
physiological activation that is the
underlying cause of
many forms of insomnia
but
coming back to sex the data is actually
quite compelling
that both either subjectively assessed
sleep quality or objective amount of
sleep
sex that has resulted in orgasm and i
think it's that latter part that
typically needs to happen i would
imagine so um that you know so between
two mutually exclusive uh individuals um
were both are
you know beneficial in terms of
receiving an orgasm yeah i would say any
discussion about sex we were referring
to
consensual
age age-appropriate
species appropriate context approach wow
i would never have even gone by the
species in there because it's the
internet and people will come up with
all sorts of ideas so i i think that
age-appropriate i think age-appropriate
consensual
context appropriate and species
appropriate covers all the bases but if
i missed any put them in the comment
section and we'll be sure to take note
yeah no i think that's uh that's really
well said um and important to say so the
data is the
when you look at couples who have orgasm
we've also however found benefits of
masturbation
and it's not frequently spoken about but
what it
if you do some surveys it turns out that
people will often use masturbation as a
sleep tool if they're struggling with
sleep and i know this sort of sounds
almost like a strange conversation or
it's a taboo conversation but i i think
we just need to be very open about i
started off in science um one of the
things i worked on uh early in my career
not the very first topic was uh the
topic of early influences of hormones
estrogen and testosterone on sexual
development of the brain and body and
when you are weaned in a laboratory like
that
regardless of what era you look at sex
and its behaviors and its hormones and
its physiologies as a scientist and so i
think that's to be clear what we're
doing here we're exploring these um
these behaviors from that from that
perspective i mean one thing is for
certain
everyone is here because a sperm met an
egg either in a dish or in vivo as we
said before and um at least in 2021
there's there's no way around that fact
yeah um and what preceded that is
typically this act we call sex and
sometimes
hopefully uh i like to think uh orgasm
is associated with that sexual activity
masturbation as one dimension of that is
something that i think it can and should
be discussed if in fact there are data
that relate it to sleep yeah and both of
those roots seem to lead to
a sleep benefit now i'm not saying that
it's all about the orgasm i think as we
spoke about with oxytocin there is some
degree of per bonding that if you have a
partner and you experience you know an
intimate loving you know relationship
that involves that then you can have
hormonal benefits that are sleep
promoting that may not necessarily be
seen if you're just engaging you know in
the solo singular act of masturbation
so
what we certainly know and i i am not
someone to take any advice on when it
comes to and i think relationship wise
or sex wise that's a different episode
yeah
certainly and that's not a podcast
series that i'm going to be releasing
anytime soon it's going to be mostly
about uh sleep although i will touch on
i'll release a podcast on sleep and sex
but
that's the data that we have so far we
also know that it works both ways though
and it's commonly this
the same way with sleep um you know
sleep and exercise sleep and diet
how you
eat can affect how you sleep how you
sleep can affect how you eat same with
exercise and it turns out it's the same
way with sexual behavior too
so here we're talking about whether sex
can help with sleep
can sleep help with your relationship
and sex and the answer is yes it can
firstly we know and we've spoken a
little bit about this that the
reproductive hormones are under profound
sleep regulation both estrogen and
testosterone
testosterone because we hear so often
as well but women who or i should say
anyone who's interested in having higher
levels of estrogen or normal healthy
levels of estrogen
i presume the data show for estrogen
what the data also show similarly for
testosterone which is if you get too
little or poor quality of sleep
both sex steroid hormones as they're
referred to testosterone and estrogen
which are present in both males and
females and every variation thereof are
going to be diminished below normal
healthy estrogen testosterone um fsh in
women a key hormone in the regulation um
for um
kefir conception of course
all of these sex hormones seem to become
significantly disrupted when sleep
becomes of short quantity or poor
quality
we also know that in women sleep
disruption can usually lead to menstrual
cycle disruption
we know this particularly from evidence
in shift-working women where they are
nighttime shift workers they struggle
with sleep during the day often
menstruation is disrupted or even
becomes impaired
but we also know it works this way not
just for sex hormones but for sex itself
for example we found that for every one
hour of sleep extra sleep that a woman
gets her interest in becoming sexually
intimate with her partner increases by
which is you know a non-trivial amount
and then the final part of i think this
equation when it comes to sleep and sex
is your
your relationship itself and there's
some great work here from uc berkeley by
um professor serena chen
and what she found was that restless
knights
mean for far more brutal fights
in your relationship and they did this
in vice numbers of different elegant
ways and vice versa as well i mean not
that i've ever had conflict in
relationships
like you know i just this is just data
i've read i've never experienced that at
all um
so and they found reliably that sleep
would predict higher likelihood of
relationship conflict
secondly if you got into that conflict
the chances of you resolving it were
significantly lower when the parties had
not been sleeping well
part of the reason is because when you
are not well slept your empathy goes
down
so you're not you're taking more of an
abrasive stance with your partner rather
than a more agreeable stance with your
partner so at almost every dimension of
a human loving relationship sleep can
have a dramatic impact
i think these are really important
things to underscore one of the most
common
questions i get because there seems to
be a community of people on the internet
that are obsessed with this um i don't
know who they are because it's all all
this internet stuff is shouting into a
tunnel and getting comments back and
written form it's a very bizarre
conversation
so to speak um
is
whether or not sexual behavior itself
lowers or increases testosterone and i
went into the data um
which spans many decades actually both
animal studies and human studies and it
seems
just to underscore this as long as we're
talking about the subject that
it does seem that
sexual
activity sex be between two people
does seem to increase testosterone in
both
there is this question about orgasm or
no orgasm ejaculation no ejaculation and
and indeed there do seem to be some
effects of of um
of restricting ejaculation in males as a
form of further increasing testosterone
so sex without ejaculation further
increasing testosterone but the data are
not clean okay um presumably because
organizing these sorts of studies and
getting truth in in self-reporting is
probably hard to get from from subjects
but um
but it everything sort of points in the
direction
that
provided that the relationship is a
healthy one it's it's consensual it's
age appropriate context appropriate
species appropriate that sex between two
individuals does seem to increase the
sex droid hormones testosterone and
estrogen toward healthy ranges and what
i'm hearing now the sort of gestalt of
the discussion we just had is that that
too can promote
sleepiness restful states and quality
sleep and um i think this is an
important conversation that just hasn't
been held enough i mean sooner or later
um both in the u.s and elsewhere we're
going to have to acknowledge that we are
biological organisms of some sort and
that we have choice in life about all
these things um from supplementation to
sex or no sex etc but
that they have profound effects on our
core biology i mean it's
fascinating to me that the areas of the
hypothalamus the pre-optic area the
super-optic areas
those areas which the names might not
mean anything to anybody besides matt
and i sitting here but those areas sit
cheek to jowl with each other in the
hypothalamus and control
sleep and sex yeah the trigger of orgasm
the appetite for food yeah the appetite
for water for electrolytes i mean the
hypothalamus is kind of a um
a festival of of neurons with different
booths for different uh such as
a small structure in the brain but it's
the orchestrator of a vast number of our
behaviors disproportionate in terms of
its size versus effect yeah i don't
think you can go to this hypothalamic
festival without
uh at least seeing all the booths
whether or not you decide to visit them
or not um master analogy
so um
so
i i'm so i'm glad that we've broached
that conversation and i hope people will
um will think that we've approached it
with the appropriate level of
sensitivity it's an important one that
we're going to hear more about one way
or the other people are certainly
thinking about this if not engaging in
in these sorts of behaviors or avoiding
them um so the more we can understand
about the biology the better
and so thank you for bringing that topic
up because for the record matt uh tabled
it for discussion
i said we were just like chatting
outside and i think we said something
about the sensitive section yeah we can
go that's absolutely interesting
absolutely um
i want to touch on just two remaining
topics
one is
are there any unconventional sleep tips
or things about sleep that that we've
overlooked if we've covered everything
great but um you know we're here to keep
the room cool we here uh because of this
temperature phenomenon the light aspects
the considerations about alcohol cbd
marijuana
um cognitive behavioral
tart cherry fruit kiwis
perhaps perhaps please don't put me on
the hook for tot cherries i was just
offering what i know about no and these
are considerations and and whether or
not people batch these things i i won't
even list them off now because they're
too many jokes that one one could make
um
and i have no affiliation with any of
these products
i'm going to take out stock in a kiwi
company no i'm just kidding um but the
question i have is
about any unconventional or lesser-known
things or maybe you do things or you
think about things just in a purely uh
exploratory way as a scientist of the
you know the the what-if
uh kind of things that you know what if
it turns out that and i hear i just i
i've got a blank there for you to fill
in
i think you know beyond the
standard
you know fur that i've dished out plenty
of times of sleep hygiene of you know
regularity temperature darkness
um alcohol caffeine and we've we've
spoken about all of those
what are some more unconventional tips i
guess
the first one which is unconventional
along the lines of naps
if you've had a bad night of sleep let's
say that you're starting to emerge with
insomnia and you've had a bad night of
sleep the advice and i learned this from
my wonderful colleague michael perlis
do nothing
what i mean by that is
don't wake up any later don't sleep in
the following day to try and make up for
it don't nap during the day
don't consume extra caffeine to wake you
up to try to get you through the day and
don't go to bed any earlier to think
that you're going to compensate
and i can explain all of those things
but if you wake up later you're not
going to be sleepy until later the
evening so you're going to go to bed at
your normal time and you won't be
sleeping you'll think well i just came
off a bad night of sleep and now i still
i'm i can't even get to sleep and it's
my normal time it's because you slept in
later than you would otherwise and you
reduce the window of adenosine
accumulation before your normal bedtime
so don't go don't wake up any later
don't use more caffeine for the reasons
that are obvious because that's only
going to crank you and keep you awake
the following night or
decrease the probability of a good
following night of recovery sleep
third um i mentioned don't take naps
because once again that will just take
you know naps particularly later in the
afternoon i almost liken them to
snacking before a main meal it just
takes your appetite off the edge of that
main meal of sleep so don't do it and
then finally don't go to bed any earlier
resist and resist and go to bed at your
normal time what i want to try and do is
prevent you from thinking i had such a
bad night last night and i normally go
to bed at 10 30. i'm just gonna get into
bed at nine o'clock because last night
was just so bad but that's not your
natural bedtime and it's not aligned
with your natural chrono type because
presumably you kind of know something
about that or a morning type evening
time you're trying to sleep in harmony
which is usually how you get best
quality sleep but you go to bed at nine
and my body is not ready to to sleep at
nine o'clock
but i'm worried because i had a bad
night of sleep last night so i get into
bed and now i'm tossing and turning for
the first hour and a half because it's
not my natural sleep window but i just
thought it was a good idea
and if i didn't know anything about
sleep i would think all of these same
things too so i'm not finger wagging but
after if i have a bad night of sleep and
i am not immune just because i know a
little bit about sleep doesn't mean i
don't have my bad nights i do doesn't
mean i haven't had bouts of insomnia in
my life i have
but after a bad night of sleep i do
nothing i don't do any of those four
things
i think the second tip
i would offer in terms of unconventional
is have a wind-down routine
many of us think of sleep
as if it's like a light switch
that we just jump into bed and when we
turn the light out sleep should arrive
in that same way
just the binary you know it's on or it's
off sleep is a physiological process
it's much more like landing a plane it
takes time to gradually descend down
onto the terra firma of what we call
good solid sleep at night
find out whatever works for you and it
could be light stretching i usually
meditate
for about 10 or 15 minutes uh before bed
some people like reading
try not to watch television in bed
that's usually advised too much
too much light too activating you know
you can listen to a relaxing podcast
although we can speak about technology
in the bedroom too but
have some kind of a wind down routine
it's
you know it's almost like you know you
wouldn't race into your garage and come
to a
screeching halt from 60 miles an hour
you typically down
shift your gears and you slow down as
you come into the carriage this is the
same thing with with sleep too so that's
the second thing have some kind of a
wind down routine find what works for
you maybe it's taking a hot bath or a
warm shower
and then stick to it just we do this
with kids all the time we find out what
their bedroom sorry their bedtime
regiment is and then we just stick to it
faithfully because
but we humans are the same way too
the third thing is a myth don't count
sheep there's a study done here at uc
berkeley i didn't do this today i wish i
did it was by my colleague professor
allison harvey and they found that
counting sheep actually made it harder
to fall asleep it made matters worse
as a con sorry counter measure to that
what they did find was that taking
yourself on some kind of a mental walk
so think about a nice walk that you take
in nature or walk on the beach or even a
walk around an urban environment and
visualizing that
that seemed to be beneficial the other
thing about um sort of that idea of
shifting focus away from your mind
itself get your mind off itself is a
good
piece of advice
catharsis you can try to write down all
of the concerns that you have
and do this not right before bed but
usually an hour or two before bed
some people call call it a worry journal
and to me it's a little bit like closing
down all of the emotional tabs on my
browser
because if i shut the computer down and
all of those tabs are still open i'm
going to come back in the morning the
computer's red hot the fan's going
because it didn't go to sleep because it
couldn't because there were too many
tabs active and open i think it's the
same way with sleep as well so try to
think about doing that so just vomit out
all of your concerns on the page i like
that because my 3 am waking is often
associated with me writing down the list
of things that i forgot to do that i
need to do yeah and in in once i
eventually wake up from the later night
uh second half of the night's sleep that
stuff seems much more tractable and
reasonable but uh it sure would be great
to get that stuff out of the way before
sleep well there's also something that i
don't think people have spoken about a
lot and i'd like to research it
which is
difficulty and anxiety
at night in the dark
is not the same difficulty and anxiety
in the light of day
and when we have those thoughts at night
it comes with a magnitude of rumination
and catastrophization
that is disproportionate
to that which you would describe when
you are awake
and
i don't know what's going on about the
brain and thought and emotion at the
time i've got a bunch of theories as to
why
and that's why i like the idea of
closing up zipping up all of those
different components just
get them out on the page
and
it feel and i at first thought this just
sounds like hui it sounds very berkely
it's kind of come by our we all hold
hands and you know walk home at the end
of the day but then this the data
started coming out really good studies
from good people and they found that
keeping one of those journals decreased
the time it takes you to fall asleep by
fifty percent five zero
amazing that's well on par with any
pharmaceutical agent oh absolutely yeah
i i'm convinced that well i've long
thought that the
worries and concerns and
ideas i have at 3 4 a.m i've learned to
not place any stock in them yeah because
ever something
i'm glad that you might um decide to
eventually look at this in your
laboratory because i feel like something
is melted away or altered
i suspect it's in the uh the regulation
of the autonomic nervous system that it
makes sense why a concern at 3 4 a.m
ought to evoke more of a panic sense
than a concern sentence and certainly
that's my experience although not i'm
fortunate to not suffer from full-blown
panic attacks but everything seems worse
at 3 4 a.m provided you're awake and we
we need to sort of look into that
because you know if you look at suicide
rates
around the 24-hour clock face
disproportionately higher rates in those
middle
sort of night hours
so no now i don't know if that's
causative or not but something you know
it could just be that that's the time
when we're mostly lonely and we're by
ourselves and that's the reasons it's
got nothing to do with sleep or the
night time i don't know
um
so that's the third thing i think the
fourth sort of little tip i would give
that's unconventional is remove all
clock faces from your bedroom including
your phone including your phone
and resist checking it now i know and i
can speak about the phone too that genie
of technology is out the bottle and it's
not going back in any time soon so we've
got to think of scientists and sleep
scientists
you know as to what we do with you know
phones in the background
years ago i was a counselor at a summer
camp i worked with at-risk kids and the
um there was a phrase that comes to mind
here it's be a channel not a damn
because when you try and damn certain
kinds of behavior
um physically damn certain kinds of
behavior not morally damn um
that too uh
it just creeps over the edge and you get
it and you get a a waterfall um so it
has to be channeled the phone and
devices have to be worked with and
negotiated that's right and you know
think about those mindfully too but
clock faces
remove all of those because if you are
having you know a tough night
knowing that it's 3 22 in the morning or
it's 4 48 in the morning does not help
you in the slightest and it's only going
to make matters worse than better so try
to remove all clock faces and i think
that's one of those other tips that some
people have found helpful but those
would be sort of some slightly
unconventional i guess more than your
stock fare of here are the five tips for
sleep hygiene tonight um so those are
terrific sleep tips and um several of
which if not all of which i'm going to
incorporate um
matt this has been an amazing uh deep
dive on sleep and it's positive and
negative regulators i hope it hasn't
been too long and i i don't know this
has been great cut it down shorten it to
uh you know the five minutes of
meaningful stuff that i offer absolutely
not ever it is chock-a-block full of
valuable takeaways it's been uh
tremendously fun for me to uh dissect
out this incredible aspect of our lives
that we call sleep with a fellow
scientist and a
fellow public educator i want to say um
several things first of all um
we
should say where people can find you
although i it shouldn't be that
difficult these days you're a very
present on the on the internet um
for better for worse i think it's
wonderful that you're out there look
it's a public health service that you're
doing
no one requires you or any other
scientist to to get out and
share this information
my sense of you knowing you a bit and
from following your work very closely
with your scientific work in detail and
um your public facing uh educational
work is that you very much want the best
for people and it's it's an interesting
thing as a scientist or a clinician to
know that the that certain answers exist
that we don't have all the answers but
that there is a better path there are
better ways and people can benefit in a
myriad of ways so um for that because i
know that to be very genuine in you um
you want the best for people and you're
offering tremendous
advice and and um considerations and
people can take it or leave it that's
the way i view it i also want to thank
you for taking the time out of your day
to uh to sit with me here and have this
discussion
it's a privilege it's a delight you know
you and i
um i think were like kind in lots of
ways and
i take you as a as a shining example of
how you can effectively connect with the
public and i know that we've had our
conversations before we ever sat down
sort of together about
you know
how to think about communicating with
the public and the pros and cons of that
and i've just loved your opinions i've
been drinking it all in and then i think
the third thing i'd like to say is thank
you for being such an incredible sleep
ambassador the series that you've
released on sleep the way that you speak
about sleep the way that you moderate
and of champion sleep it is remarkable
so thank you for just being you know a
brother in arms uh in that way well we
are and and thanks for those those words
um 99 of what i discussed there was the
work of you and your colleagues in the
sleep field so proper acknowledgement
but thank you where can people
learn more about what you're doing
currently and what's coming next you're
on twitter uh i am on um twitter i
typically tweet um as the sleep dipper
man so it's it's no it's just sleep
diploma sleep diplomats
diplomat on twitter sleep diplomat.com
website uh if you want to learn more
about the science that we do here it's
humansleepscience.com it's the center
for human sleep science um
you can pick up a copy of the book if
you want it's called why we sleep if
you're curious about sleep
that's one path to take and it's is
there another like someday in the in the
future uh i think there may be yeah
right i think
many many millions of people will be
very happy to hear that i think it's
it's starting to take hold and then um
as we discussed i am
more than kicking around the idea of a
short form podcast rather than a long
form
not long form because i don't have the
mental capacity or the interviewing um
just capability that someone like you
has so it will probably just be
monologue short form so if there is some
interest i'll probably do that as well
so those are the ways that people can
find me but overall if you're interested
in sleep just listen to andrew that's
the best thing i can tell all right well
now now we're batting back and forth the
the uh vector of action so to speak but
um i do hope you'll start a podcast
however brief or lengthy these episodes
uh turn out to be because i do believe
that's a great venue to get information
out into the world and um we don't just
uh want to hear more from matt walker i
speak for many people um we need to the
work you're doing is both um influential
but more importantly it is important
work it it has the impact that's needed
especially in this day and age where
science and medicine public health
and the issues of the world etc are
really converging so
i know i speak on behalf of a tremendous
number of people and i just say thank
you for doing the work you do and for
being you and thanks for being a good
friend likewise too um and by the way i
just going to note that it was nice that
the two of us both got the um johnny
cash uh memo about how to dress today uh
it seems as though we're both kind of uh
we got that same memo which will mean
nothing to people who are listening but
if you're watching the video you'll
probably see what i mean andrew thank
you for taking this time thank you so
much so much matt
thank you for joining me for my
discussion with dr matt walker
please also check out his podcast the
matt walker podcast a link to that
podcast can be found in the show notes
if you're enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to us on youtube on youtube
you can also leave us comments and
suggestions for future episodes and
guests in the comments section as well
please subscribe to us on apple and on
spotify and at apple you can leave us up
to a five-star review you can also
support us by checking out our patreon
account that's patreon.com andrew
huberman and there you can support us at
any level that you like
please also check out our sponsors
mentioned at the beginning of this
episode links to those sponsors can be
found in the show notes
during this episode and in many previous
episodes we discussed supplements one
issue in the supplement industry is that
many supplements don't contain what's
listed on the bottle we therefore have
partnered with thorn that's t-h-o-r-n-e
thorn supplements because thorn
supplements have the highest levels of
stringency in terms of the purity of the
ingredients and precision with respect
to what's listed on the bottle is
actually what's contained in those
supplement bottles if you'd like to see
the supplements that i take for sleep
and for other things you can go to
thorn.com
letter u
huberman and there you'll see all the
supplements that i take and can get 20
off any of those supplements as well as
any other supplements that thorn happens
to make that's thorn t-h-o-r-n-e
dot com slash the letter u
huberman
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]